Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰、提前解锁全系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestisistory.com并加入俱乐部。网址是therestisistory.com。本期节目由Adobe Express赞助播出，这是一款简单快捷、能创作一切的应用。这是什么意思？嗯，假设你需要做一份演示文稿、视频、社交媒体帖子或传单，对某些人来说——尤其是对我来说——这听起来让人望而生畏。但汤姆，有了Adobe Express直观的功能，比如模板、生成式AI和实时
collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store. Terrible tale, a dark chapter in a public man's history. A pitiful story of Maria Helpin and Governor Cleveland. Some years ago, a beautiful, virtuous and intelligent young lady entered the employee of Flint and Kent, most excellent men and leading merchants in our city.
协作，这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express。免费试用。在应用商店中搜索Adobe Express。一个可怕的故事，公职人物历史上的黑暗一页。玛丽亚·哈尔平与克利夫兰州长的悲惨故事。多年前，一位美丽、贤淑且聪明的年轻女子进入了我们市最优秀的绅士、领先商人弗林特和肯特公司工作。
She was put at the head of their cloak department and served them for some two or three years to perfect satisfaction. Mr. Grover Cleveland made her acquaintance, won her confidence, and finally seduced her. She lost her position, was cast out of good society,
她被安排负责斗篷部，为他们服务了大约两到三年，表现令人极其满意。格罗弗·克利夫兰先生结识了她，赢得了她的信任，并最终诱奸了她。她失去了职位，被排挤出上流社会，
and driven to despair. Poor Maria Helpin, for that was her name, went away broken-hearted, disgraced and outcast, while her seducer continued to revel in the realm of lust and pretend before the great American public that he is a model of virtue, preeminently worthy of being honoured by their votes. Perhaps personal character originally ought not to be involved in political discussions, but it would be criminal to allow the virtuous to vote for so vile a man as this, under a false impression, that he is pure and honourable. it is painful to think of his offences and shameful infinitely shameful to have such a man commended to the suffrages of a Christian nation
并被逼入绝境。可怜的玛丽亚·哈尔平——这就是她的名字——带着破碎的心、耻辱和被抛弃的命运黯然离去，而她的诱奸者却继续在荒淫的世界里寻欢作乐，并在伟大的美国公众面前假装自己是美德的典范，极其配得上他们选票的荣誉。或许个人品格原本不该卷入政治讨论，但如果允许有道德的人在虚假的印象下投票给这样一个卑鄙的人，认为他纯洁而高尚，那将是犯罪。一想到他的罪行就令人感到痛苦，而把这样一个人推荐给一个基督教国家的选民，更是令人感到无比羞耻、无限羞耻。
it is enough to alarm all decent people and cause even the vulgar and profane to hesitate and demand a halt So that, Dominic, the dramatic front page of the Buffalo Evening Telegraph on the 21st of July 1884, breaking the news of perhaps the most lurid sex scandal in American political history. And that is setting the bar quite high, isn't it? It is, because they've had some tremendous sex scandals, haven't they? In our own lifetimes, Tom. There have been all kinds of goings on in the White House. I think back to the behavior of Bill Clinton, which I think now, when you look back on it, was pretty poor.
这足以惊动所有正派的人，甚至让粗俗和亵渎神明的人都犹豫不决并要求悬崖勒马。所以，多米尼克，1884年7月21日《布法罗晚报》充满戏剧性的头版，爆出了美国政治史上或许最耸人听闻的性丑闻。这把标准定得相当高，不是吗？确实很高，因为他们在历史上经历过一些轰动的性丑闻，对吧？在我们自己的一生中，汤姆。白宫里发生过各种各样的风流韵事。我想起比尔·克林顿的行为，现在回想起来，我觉得相当糟糕。
I don't think there's any defending it, really. And this is describing Mr. Grave Cleveland as a presidential candidate. Yes. Presidential candidates being accused of sexual impropriety. I mean, it has been heard of even in the 21st century. Even in the 21st century, there's a rich tradition of it. But this is in a different league. So on the face of it, this story is a side.
我觉得这真的没什么可辩护的。而这篇报道是在形容格罗弗·克利夫兰先生作为总统候选人。是的。总统候选人被指控性行为不端。我的意思是，即使在21世纪，这也是有所耳闻的。即使在21世纪，这也是一项悠久的传统。但这次完全不在一个级别上。所以表面上看，这个故事是一次
of lust and lies and kidnapping and rape that is worthy of a Victorian sensation novel. So it often reads those listeners who've read The Moonstone or the Woman in White in particular by Wilkie Collins, the kind of sensation fiction of the mid-19th century, there is a stolen baby, there is a grotesquely fat villain. It's Count Fosco, isn't it? It's Count Fosco in the Woman in White. There is a widow imprisoned in a lunatic asylum. to stop her telling the truth.
充满色欲、谎言、绑架和强奸的事件，堪比维多利亚时代的小说。读过维尔基·柯林斯《月亮宝石》或特别是《白衣女人》的听众往往会有这种感觉，这就是19世纪中叶那种耸人听闻的小说，里面有被偷走的孩子，有一个胖得离谱的恶棍。那是福斯科伯爵，对吧？就是《白衣女人》里的福斯科伯爵。还有一个被囚禁在精神病院里的寡妇，为了阻止她说出真相。
But also, this is a story of massive political significance because it breaks during one of the most hotly contested presidential elections in American history. So we're in the Gilded Age, Tom, in 1884, and that for people who are not massively familiar with American history, it's the era after the Civil War, it's factories, tycoons, railroads, sort of men with colossal beards, women with gigantic, ball gowns. I mean, Dominic, this is the kind of political era that Custer would have entered had he
但同时，这也是一个具有重大政治意义的故事，因为它爆发于美国历史上竞争最激烈的总统选举之一。所以我们身处镀金时代，汤姆，在1884年，对于那些对美国历史不太熟悉的人来说，这是内战之后的时代，到处是工厂、大亨、铁路，还有留着巨大的胡子、穿着巨型大礼服的女人。我的意思是，多米尼克，如果卡斯特没有
not run into the Sioux at Little Bigmore. That's right. Exactly. Exactly. So 1884 is a really, really important year because for the first time since before the Civil War, the Republicans, Abraham Lincoln's party, are in real danger of losing the White House. So a generational shift politically, and the man who is poised to beat them is Governor Grover Cleveland of New York. Now, I'm guessing quite a lot of people listen to this will not really be massively familiar with his career. Are you familiar with his career, Tom? Well, I was because he is one of those pub quiz questions that was always a banker, because he was, until very recently, the only president to have served a term, lost an election, and then won again.
在小大霍恩河遭遇苏族人，他也会进入这种政治时代。没错。完全正确。所以1884年是一个非常非常重要的年份，因为自内战之前以来，共和党——亚伯拉罕·林肯的政党——首次面临失去白宫的真正危险。因此这是一次政治上的代际更迭，而准备击败他们的人是纽约州州长格罗弗·克利夫兰。现在，我猜听这档节目的很多人对他的政治生涯并不是特别熟悉。你熟悉他的职业生涯吗，汤姆？嗯，我很熟悉，因为他是那种总会在酒吧知识问答里作为稳赚不赔的考题出现的人物，因为直到不久前，他还是唯一一位当选总统、输掉选举、然后又再次赢得大选的人。
Yes. And you know, you could go into a couple of ways knowing there was a strong likelihood that question would come up and you could bank your point. And then Donald Trump completely ruined it by doing exactly the same. Well, Donald Trump has had a pretty incredible rise to political prominence. But Grover Cleveland's in some ways is even more extraordinary. So at the age of 44, right, Cleveland was basically a nobody. He was a lawyer in Buffalo, a New York, quite a successful lawyer, but he'd only ever had one political job. which is the sheriff of Erie County.
是的。你知道，你可以通过几种方式确信这道题极大概率会出现，从而稳拿分数。然后唐纳德·特朗普通过做完全相同的事，彻底把这事给毁了。好吧，唐纳德·特朗普在政治上的崛起确实相当不可思议。但在某些方面，格罗弗·克利夫兰的经历甚至更加非凡。所以在44岁的时候，没错，克利夫兰基本上是个无名小卒。他是纽约州布法罗的一名律师，相当成功的律师，但他一生中只做过一份政治工作，
And he'd had that job a decade earlier and then left it and gone back to kind of his legal practice. And then he has this four-year period where he becomes mayor of Buffalo and then governor of New York. And then in 1884, he's nominated by the Democrats as their candidate to become the 22nd president of the United States.
那就是伊利县治安官。他在十年前做过那份工作，然后辞职回到了律师事务所。接着他迎来了为期四年的时期，先后成为了布法罗市长和纽约州州长。然后在1884年，他被民主党提名为美国第22任总统候选人。
So basically he comes from nowhere in the space of four years. Yeah, it's a meteor, right? And then he's president, he loses, and then he becomes president together. And for about half a century after he left office, he had quite a high reputation. So in the 1930s, there was a very distinguished American journalist called H.L. Mencken, who wrote, we have had more brilliant presidents than Cleveland and one or two who are considerably more profound, but we've never had one, at least since Washington, whose fundamental character was more admirable.
所以他基本上在四年的时间里凭空崛起。是的，犹如流星一般，对吧？然后他当上了总统，输了，接着又再次当上总统。在他卸任后的半个世纪里，他享有相当高的声望。所以在20世纪30年代，有一位非常杰出的美国记者名叫H·L·门肯，他写道：“我们有过比克利夫兰更聪明的总统，也有一两位深刻得多，但我们从未有过一位——至少自华盛顿以来——其根本品格更令人钦佩。”
And I mean, that's quite a telling testimony, isn't it? Because Mencken was, I mean, he was a satirist as well as a journalist. he would mock what he saw as ridiculous. He reported on the Scopes trial, basically putting Darwinism on trial. And so the fact that he didn't see Cleveland as an immoral man or a ridiculous man, I mean, that's striking. It is very striking. But Tom, of course, if the story you opened with is true, absolutely. And then Mencken was wrong. And if Mencken was wrong and the story is true, then Grover Cleveland was not merely a liar, a bully. He was a sexual abuse. He was a sexual possibly a rapist, a man who locked his victim in a mental hospital to keep her quiet.
我的意思是，这是一个相当意味深长的证词，不是吗？因为门肯他不仅是一位记者，还是一位讽刺作家。他会嘲笑那些他认为荒谬的事物。他报道了斯科普斯审判，那场审判实际上是将达尔文主义推上了被告席。因此，他并不认为克利夫兰是一个不道德的人或荒谬的人，这让人印象深刻。确实非常深刻。但是汤姆，当然，如果你开篇讲的故事是真的，那就另当别论了。如果门肯错了，而那个故事是真的，那么格罗弗·克利夫兰不仅是个骗子、霸凌者，他还是个性虐待者。他甚至可能是一个强奸犯，一个把受害人锁在精神病院里以让她保持沉默的人。
So like a figure from Victorian melodrama. Completely. Now, I said if it's true, this is the question. Is this story true? Is Grover Cleveland one of the great villains in American political history? Or is he one of the great victims, a victim of one of its cruelest smears? So today's episode, it's both a brilliant window into the politics of the Gilded Age, but it's a very thrilling detective story in which you will sift the evidence.
就像维多利亚时代情节剧里的反派。完全如此。现在，我说如果这是真的，问题就在这里。这个故事是真的吗？格罗弗·克利夫兰是美国政治史上最伟大的恶棍之一吗？还是说他是最伟大的受害者之一，成了美国政治中最残酷的污蔑之下的牺牲品？所以今天的节目，既是一扇窥探镀金时代政治的绝佳窗口，也是一个扣人心弦的侦探故事，你将在其中仔细甄别证据。
So again, like Wilkie Collins. Like Wilkie Collins, exactly. So maybe we should kick off at Grover Cleveland himself, because I'm guessing that a lot of listeners won't be overly familiar with the details of his career. Grover's a great name. Got to say that. Putting that on the record. Well, there's a Muppet called Grover, isn't it?
所以，就像维尔基·柯林斯一样。就像维尔基·柯林斯，完全没错。所以我们或许应该从格罗弗·克利夫兰本人切入，因为我猜很多听众对他的职业生涯细节不会太熟悉。格罗弗是个很棒的名字。我得这么说。把它记录在案。嗯，有个布偶叫格罗弗，对吧？
Who's named after Grover Cleveland, I believe. So that's exciting. Yeah, that is exciting. All right. So Grover Cleveland was born in New Jersey in 1837. He's the fifth of nine children. His father is a Presbyterian minister. So he has a very strict Presbyterian upbringing.
据我所知，它就是以格罗弗·克利夫兰的名字命名的。所以这很令人兴奋。是的，这确实令人兴奋。好吧。所以格罗弗·克利夫兰于1837年出生于新泽西州。他是九个孩子中的老五。他的父亲是一位长老会牧师。所以他有着非常严格的长老会家庭背景。
We're going to be sifting Grover Cleveland's kind of moral, the record of his personal morality. He had a very strict Presbyterian upbringing. The kids and the Cleveland household weren't allowed to play on Sundays. They had to go to two church services to Sunday school and to a prayer meeting on Sundays, which seems too much to me. And all the sense that we have of him as a boy is he's actually quite dull, serious, self-disciplined. He's quite gruff and kind of laconic when he grows up. So he's not
我们将要仔细审查格罗弗·克利夫兰的道德记录，即他个人品德的档案。他有着非常严格的长老会家庭背景。克利夫兰家的小孩星期天是不准出去玩的。他们星期天必须去教堂做两次礼拜、上主日学并参加祷告会，这在我看来实在有点过分了。我们对他童年的所有印象是，他其实相当沉闷、严肃、自律。他长大后显得相当粗犷、言简意赅。所以他
really a very flamboyant character. Could this be the mask of an unspeakable hypocrite? Exactly. Well, this is the question. So when he's 16, his father dies and a local Presbyterian deacon said to Grover, if you'd like to follow him into the church, I will pay for your education. And Grover Cleveland said, no, it's not for me, thank you. I'm going to seek my fortune at West. So off he goes. And his plan, ironically, is to go to Cleveland, but halfway between where he is, New Jersey or whatever, and he wants to go to Cleveland, Ohio. Halfway is Buffalo, New York. And he decides to stop there because his uncle Lewis is there, and he's made lots of money in insurance and has set up as a farmer as well. Now, Buffalo is a very good place for him to be stopping. It is a boomtown. It's a classic 19th century boomtown. Buffalo is the main inland, port between the Great Lakes and the Atlantic. So at this point, sort of mid-century, it's the world's largest grain port and the second largest railway hub in the whole of the United States.
并不是一个非常张扬的角色。这会不会是一个不可言说的伪君子的伪装呢？没错。这就是问题所在。所以当他16岁时，他的父亲去世了，当地的一位长老会执事对格罗弗说：“如果你愿意步你父亲的后尘进入教会，我来支付你的教育费用。”而格罗弗·克利夫兰说：“不，这不适合我，谢谢。我要去西部寻找我的财富。”于是他出发了。讽刺的是，他的计划是去克利夫兰，但从他当时所在地（新泽西或其他地方）到他想去的俄亥俄州克利夫兰，中间正好隔了一个布法罗，纽约州。他决定在那里停下来，因为他的叔叔刘易斯在那里，而且他在保险业赚了大笔钱，还当起了农场主。现在，布法罗对他来说是个非常好的落脚点。这是一座淘金热城市。它是一座典型的19世纪繁荣城市。布法罗是五大湖和大西洋之间主要内陆港口。因此在这个时期，即世纪中期，它是世界上最大的谷物港口，也是全美第二大铁路枢纽。
Is it after Chicago? I think it is after Chicago. So the West is being opened up, basically. Exactly. So its population has grown tenfold in 30 years from 8 to 80,000. It's doubling again in the next 30 years or so. It's a very, it's a boom town, but it's a rough town. So there's a street called Canal Street running along the Erie Canal, said to be the wickedest street in America, or people call it the infected district.
它是排在芝加哥后面吗？我想是的，是在芝加哥之后。所以当时西部正在被大规模开发。完全正确。因此在30年里，其人口增长了十倍，从8000人增加到8万。在接下来的30年左右里，人口又翻了一番。这是一座繁荣的城市，但也是一个粗野的地方。因此，沿着伊利运河有一条名为运河街的街道，据说是美国最邪恶的街道，人们也称其为感染区。
So maybe this is why Grover Cleveland didn't stop there. Maybe, tell me, because it's lined with saloons and brothels, and it's said to be more dangerous than anywhere in the World West, so the police have to patrol in threes. Now, if you're of Tom's more cynical disposition, you'd say, what a surprise that it's here that Grover Cleveland decides to see. is wandering. Yes, escaping his mission to become a minister in the church, to settle down in a town famous for its brothels. I think actually it's nothing to do with the brothels. It's basically because he kind of, it's a boom town and his uncle Lewis says, I'll get you an internship with the local law firm. And he really takes to it. He's admitted to the New York State Bar in 1859 when he's 22. Now, just two years later, the American Civil War is going to break out. Now, Grover
所以也许这就是格罗弗·克利夫兰没有在那里停留的原因？或许吧，告诉我，因为那里到处都是酒吧和妓院，据说比美国旧西部的任何地方都要危险，所以警察都得三人一组进行巡逻。现在，如果你抱有汤姆那种更为愤世嫉俗的心态，你就会说：难怪格罗弗·克利夫兰决定留在这里。没错，逃避了他成为教会牧师的使命，在一个以妓院闻名的城镇安顿下来。我认为这其实和妓院一点关系都没有。主要原因在于，这是一座淘金热城市，他的叔叔刘易斯说：“我帮你找个当地律所的实习生职位。”他真的很喜欢这份工作。他在1859年22岁时获得了纽约州律师资格。仅仅两年后，美国内战就要爆发了。现在，格罗弗
is not, despite the fact that he's a Presbyterian and Presbyterians are overrepresented in the Republican Party, he's not a Republican. He sees the abolitionists. He thinks they're extremists. He's not a pro-slavery person, but he thinks the Democrats are more moderate. So he becomes a Democrat. And he actually campaigns for James Buchanan, one of the worst presidents in American history in 1856. And in 1860, he doesn't vote for Abraham Lincoln. He votes for the Democratic candidate, Stephen Douglas. So the war breaks out, and he doesn't fancy it. Under the conscription act, you could pay somebody else to take your place for you if you were conscripted. So when he is conscripted in 1863, he pays an illiterate Polish immigrant called George Biniski, $150 to serve in his place.
尽管他是个长老会信徒，而长老会信徒在共和党中比例过高，但他并不是个共和党人。他看不惯废奴主义者。他认为他们是极端分子。他不是一个支持蓄奴的人，但他认为民主党更为温和。所以他成了一名民主党人。他在1856年实际上为詹姆斯·布坎南——美国历史上最糟糕的总统之一——拉过选票。而在1860年，他没有投亚伯拉罕·林肯的票，他投给了民主党候选人斯蒂芬·道格拉斯。然后战争爆发了，而他对此毫无兴趣。根据征兵法案，如果你被征召入伍，你可以花钱找别人代替你服役。所以在1863年他被征召入伍时，他付给了一个名叫乔治·比尼斯基的文盲波兰移民150美元，让他们代替自己服役。
And later on, when this came out, because obviously it's not ideal for Cleveland's political career that he didn't serve, he is completely unrepentant. He says, look, I was allowed to do it, I paid this bloke, I actually paid him over the odds, which is true. Cleveland paid him quite handsomely. And this bloke Benisky, later on, Republicans said, oh, this guy Benisky, he served in Grave of Cleveland's place, and he went through unspeakable horrors. I mean, he did go through one unspeakable horror, but this was nothing really to do with the war.
后来，当这件事曝光后——因为显而易见，没有服过兵役对克利夫兰的政治生涯来说并非理想状态——他毫无悔意。他说：“听着，法律允许我这么做，我付钱给这家伙了，而且我付给他的实际上还高出市价呢。”这倒不假。克利夫兰确实付给他一笔相当可观的报酬。而这个叫比尼斯基的家伙，后来共和党人说：“哦，这个叫比尼斯基的家伙，他代替格罗弗·克利夫兰服役，他经历了难以言喻的恐怖。”我的确，他确实经历了一次难以言喻的恐怖，但这与战争其实毫无关系。
Beniske was unloading a supply wagon when, unfortunately, he suffered a testicular torsion. What is that? So some form of spermatic cord becomes wrapped around your testicle and sort of twists it. And unless you're operated on, instantly, pretty much instantly, unless the testicle is removed, you know, you could get gangrene or you could get all sorts of horrors. So, yeah. We had the guy who kills Booth, cutting off his
比尼斯基当时正在卸一辆补给马车，不幸的是，他患上了精索扭转。那是什么？就是某种形式的精索缠绕在你的睾丸上并将其扭曲。除非你立即接受手术，几乎是马上手术，除非切除睾丸，否则你知道的，你可能会得坏疽或者遭遇各种可怕的后果。所以，是的。我们之前聊过刺杀林肯的凶手布思被割掉
testicles. Boston Corbett. And now we've got another kind of civil war period testicular theme. I mean, what's going on in America at this time? Yeah, something in the water, clearly. Well, anyway, this guy had it removed, and then he was as right as rain. And Cleveland actually went and visited him in hospital, which I think reflects very well on him. Because it's not like they were great pals. Cleveland just paid him to take his place. But Cleveland went to see how he was doing. Now, in the meantime, Cleveland's legal career is absolutely thriving.
睾丸的事件，波士顿·科比特。现在我们又遇到了另一个内战时期的睾丸相关话题。我的意思是，这时期美国到底怎么了？是的，显然水质有问题。无论如何，这家伙切除了那个部位，然后他就完全恢复健康了。克利夫兰甚至还去医院探望了他，我觉得这非常体现他的为人。因为他们并不是什么好朋友。克利夫兰只是付钱让他替自己服役，但克利夫兰还是去看看他恢复得怎么样。与此同时，克利夫兰的律师生涯正蓬勃发展。
He opens a law firm. He makes lids of money. He gets a reputation for what one of his colleagues calls, his indomitable industry, his unpretentious courage, and unswerving honesty. Dominic, could I read you something from the Bodleon? Oh, my gosh. Wikipedia features.
他开了一家律师事务所。他赚了大笔钱。他因一位同事所称的“不屈不挠的勤奋、不加掩饰的勇气和坚定不移的正直”而享有盛誉。多米尼克，我能给你读一段来自博德利图书馆的记载吗？哦，天哪。维基百科特色。
We haven't had Wikipedia on the rest of history for ages. So this is what it says in the Bodleon. Yeah, go for it. Cleveland assumed a lifestyle of simplicity. taking residence in a plain boarding house. He devoted his growing income to the support of his mother and younger sisters. But again, what if it's all afront?
我们好久没在《历史的余烬》里提到维基百科了。这就是博德利图书馆里写的内容。好的，请读吧。克利夫兰过着简朴的生活方式，
Well, but this all makes him sound incredibly dreary. Does, doesn't it? But he's not actually. He's a great laugh. So places like Buffalo Boomtowns are full of bachelors of this, of sort of in their 20s and 30s, because men greatly outnumber women.
住在一家简陋的寄宿公寓里。他将不断增长的收入用于资助母亲和年轻的妹妹们。但话说回来，如果这一切都只是表面现象呢？
And Cleveland is a proper man's man. So he will spend his evenings. When he's not working, he goes to a saloon or a beer, hall. He smokes cigars. He plays poker with the lads. He just has a brilliant time. He's barely straining against the buttons of his florid waistcoat. He looks, he looks exactly as he should. So he's an enormous man, six feet tall. He's got a gigantic walrus mustache. Now, Buffalo has become a popular sort of magnet for German immigrants. So there are loads of
好吧，但所有这些都让他听起来极其沉闷。听起来确实如此，对吧？但他实际上并不是那样。他是个很有趣的人。因此，像布法罗这样的淘金热城市充满了二三十岁的单身汉，因为男性的数量远多于女性。
German beer halls and places serving sausages. And this is basically Cleveland's diet. So Cleveland starts to become incredibly fat. His friends call him either Big Steve or Uncle Jumbo. So here he is. Uncle Jumbo or Big Steve. And everybody thinks he's brilliant. He's a great fun. He loves a sort of a tall tail, a massive cigar, all of this. The only thing that diminishes his sense of genial swagger, Tom, he's got, he's basically got, I hate to say this, he's got your voice. Oh, manly. People say he's got a voice that's perhaps slightly more sensitive than you would expect from such a big man. Does that seem fair to you?
克利夫兰是个地道的男子汉。所以他的夜晚通常是这样度过的。不工作的时候，他会去酒吧或啤酒馆。他抽雪茄。他和小伙子们打扑克。他过得很愉快。他的衣服扣子几乎被他那花哨的马甲撑得快要崩开了。他看起来——他看起来完全就该是这个样子。所以他是个身材魁梧的人，身高六英尺。他留着一把巨大的海象式胡须。现在，布法罗已经成了吸引德国移民的热门磁铁。所以那里有大量的德国啤酒馆和供应香肠的场所。基本上这就是克利夫兰的饮食习惯。因此，克利夫兰开始变得胖得惊人。他的朋友们要么叫他“大史蒂夫”，要么叫他“巨无霸叔叔”。所以他就是这样一个人。巨无霸叔叔或大史蒂夫。每个人都觉得他棒极了。他非常有趣，喜欢讲大话、抽巨大的雪茄，诸如此类。唯一削减了他那温和自负感的因素是，汤姆，他有——我实在不愿意这么说，他有着你的嗓音。哦，真有男子气概。人们说他的嗓音可能比你对这么大块头的男人所期待的要稍微敏感一些。你觉得这公平吗？
There's nothing wrong with that. Yeah. So on the one hand, he's very boring and lives a life of simplicity. And on the other hand, he's out necking sausages and hanging out with the lads. They seem hard to integrate. I think in Gilded Age America, that's a popular combination. So he's living his life of austerity and then he's going out on the town. I think he works hard and blaze hard.
这没什么不对的。所以一方面，他非常无聊，过着简朴的生活。另一方面，他又在外面大吃香肠、和年轻小伙子们鬼混。这两点似乎很难融合。我认为在镀金时代的美国，这是一个很受欢迎的组合。所以他一方面过着苦行僧般的生活，另一方面又出去夜夜笙歌。我想他工作努力，玩得也尽兴。
That's what he does. He's got this great pal, who's his sort of Charles Brandon to his Henry the 8th, who is called Oscar Folsom. Oscar Folsom is much more of a rake than Cleveland is. He likes hunting and gambling. He likes carriage races. Oh, like Prince Philip. Yes, like Prince Philip.
这就是他的作风。他有一个非常要好的朋友，就像查理·布兰登对亨利八世那样，名叫奥斯卡·福尔松。奥斯卡·福尔松比克利夫兰更像个浪荡子。他喜欢打猎和赌博。他喜欢赛马车。哦，就像菲利普亲王一样。是的，就像菲利普亲王。
Or Mark Anthony, I suppose. So people should remember this book, Oscar Folsom, because he will play a part in the detective story to come. So meanwhile, Grover's had this little down. in politics. The Buffalo Democratic Party is thriving because it appeals to immigrants in particular, so Irish, German immigrants and so on. The Republican Party always had a nativist element to it, so immigrants tend to be drawn to the Democrats. And in the 1870s, early 1870s, the Democrats get Grover to run as Erie County Sheriff, and he wins, and
或者我想就像马可·安东尼。所以人们应该记住这个叫奥斯卡·福尔松的人，因为他将在接下来的侦探故事中扮演一个角色。与此同时，格罗弗在政坛上崭露头角。布法罗民主党蓬勃发展，因为它特别吸引移民，比如爱尔兰移民、德国移民等等。共和党总是带有某种本土主义色彩，所以移民往往倾向于加入民主党。在19世纪70年代初，民主党让格罗弗竞选伊利县治安官，他赢了，
he takes the oath of office surrounded by old his mates. They're drinking whiskey and smoking massive cigars. It's very kind of, you know, deadwood in an atmosphere. He'd be played by Ian McShane. So he does this for four years and then he goes back to his legal career, very successful. Can I just tell you something interesting from, that I again picked up from the Bodlian. Yeah, too. Which during his term of office as sheriff, he personally executes two murderers. One of them are matricide. And normally, you know, if you're a sheriff, you pay a deputy to do it for you. But he personally, I don't know, what do you do? Do you hang them? What do you do? Yeah, I think they were hanged. I think it was very troubling for him, actually. He wrestled with it. He didn't enjoy it, but he wanted to do it personally because he said, this is my responsibility. You know, I just have to suck this up.
他在老友们的簇拥下宣誓就职。他们喝着威士忌，抽着雪茄。这非常有那种《死木》的氛围。他大概会由伊恩·麦柯肖恩来扮演。他干了四年治安官，然后又回到了非常成功的法律生涯中。我能跟你分享一件有趣的事吗，这是我同样从博德利图书馆了解到的。请讲。在其担任治安官任期内，他亲自处决了两名杀人犯。其中一人是弑母凶手。通常情况下，如果你是治安官，你会付钱给副手代劳。但他亲自——我不知道，你用什么行刑？你绞死他们吗？是的，我认为他们是被绞死的。这对他来说其实非常困扰。他曾为此挣扎过。他并不喜欢这样做，但他想亲自执行，因为他说：“这是我的责任。你知道，我只能把这苦果咽下去。”
Okay. So actually, what seemed to reflect badly on him actually reflects well on him. Yeah. He's not a murderer. Okay. I was wondering if perhaps this reflected a relish for inflicting cruelty on people or something. No, I happen to know, as we will come to you later, that one of Cleveland's biographers is a keen listen to this podcast, so he will be appalled by this. Okay, I'm just, you know, groping my way to try and get a handle on his character. Absolutely fine. So he does the sheriff thing for four years, then he goes back to his legal career. There's only one shadow, which is that his mate, Oscar, has a carriage accident.
好吧。所以原本看起来对他不利的事情，实际上对他的名声很有利。是的。他可不是个杀人犯。好吧。我只是在想，这是否反映了他对施加残忍惩罚的嗜好什么的。不，我恰好知道，正如我们稍后会提到的，克利夫兰的一位传记作家是本播客的忠实听众，他听到这话会被吓坏的。好吧，我只是在（摸索着）试图理解他的性格。完全没问题。所以他干了四年治安官，然后又重回法律界。唯一的阴影是他的好友奥斯卡遭遇了一起马车事故。
Basically, he's racing this carriage or riding this carriage. He hits a wagon. He falls out of the carriage, and then he's run over by his own horse. horse and carriage. So he's killed and Oscar leaves a widow called Emma and a daughter called Francis. Now, you know, Emma is in her sort of 30s or something. Francis's, the daughter is just 11 years old. Now, Cleveland is now almost 40. He is made the executor of Oscar's will and Francis's legal guardian. So she is now technically, uh-oh, his legal ward. She doesn't live with him. It's just a sort of formality.
基本上，他当时在赛马车或者驾驶马车。他撞上了一辆货车。他从马车上摔了下来，然后被他自己的马和马车碾压了。
And actually, at the time, a lot of people say, well, probably what will happen is that Grover will end up marrying Emma or marry the widow. Because, you know, they're pals and stuff. It just seems the natural thing to do. So this is a slight soap opera dimension, I think, to Grover Cleveland's story. And we shall return to it to see whether he does marry Emma and what happens to Francis. So we get to 1881. Grover's now, what is he? When was he born?
因此他丧命了，奥斯卡留下了一位名叫埃玛的遗孀和一个名叫弗朗西斯的女儿。现在，埃玛正处于30多岁的年纪。弗朗西斯，也就是女儿，当时只有11岁。克利夫兰此时快40岁了。他被指定为奥斯卡遗嘱的执行人和弗朗西斯的法定监护人。所以从技术上讲，她现在成了——哦噢——他的法定被监护人。她并不跟他住在一起。这只是一种形式而已。
1837, was it? So he's, yeah. So I'm doing this as live maths. How old is he, Dominic? He's in his early 40s. So the Democrats need somebody to run as mayor of Buffalo. The big issue of the day in Buffalo, as in everywhere else in America, is corruption. You know, the huge capitalist boom of the Gilded Age, the railroads and stuff,
事实上，当时很多人说，很可能发生的情况是格罗弗最后会娶埃玛，也就是迎娶遗孀。因为，你知道的，他们是好朋友之类的事。这似乎是顺理成章的事。所以我觉得格罗弗·克利夫兰的故事中包含着某种肥皂剧般的维度。我们稍后会回到这一点，看看他是否真的娶了埃玛，以及弗朗西斯后来怎么样了。所以我们来到了1881年。格罗弗现在——他多大了？他是什么时候出生的？
that's generated lots of opportunities for patronage and for back scratching, and corruption is the big issue of the day. They want someone with clean hands, and they say to Cleveland, you're the person. He becomes the mayor. He runs the same. city very efficiently. He cleans up the government. He cuts a lot of kind of patronage projects, cuts a lot of spending. Of course, that goes down very well with taxpayers. And he starts to get a good reputation more widely. So a year later, the New York State Democrats ask him to run for governor
1837年，对吧？所以他——是的。我正在做现场数学计算。他多大了，多米尼克？他四十岁出头。所以民主党需要有人竞选布法罗市长。当时布法罗乃至全美上下最核心的议题就是腐败。你知道的，镀金时代巨大的资本繁荣，铁路等等，
of New York. Now, the reason they've asked him as an outsider is that New York party, like so many of these political parties, is riven by feuding. So, Cleveland runs. The Republicans are divided themselves between lots of factions. So he gets lots of crossover Republican votes. He takes the oath of office January 1883, Governor in New York, and he says, you know, it's going to be all about competence and efficiency and clean government. And everybody says, oh, this is tremendous. There's only one downside with Cleveland as a political package, which is that he's now, he's been eating sausages all this time. So he's now absolutely enormous. He's now 20 stone. And one New York,
创造了大量的利益输送和利益勾兑机会，腐败成了当时最热门的话题。他们需要一个双手干净的人，于是他们对克利夫兰说：“你就是我们要找的人。”他当选了市长。他把这座城市治理得井井有条。他整顿了政府。他砍掉了许多带有裙带关系的项目，削减了大量开支。当然，这赢得了纳税人的一片叫好声。他开始获得更广泛的好评。因此一年后，纽约州民主党人邀请他竞选纽约州长。
Porter said, his skin hangs on his cheeks, thick, unhealthy looking folds. The coat buttoned about his large chest and abdomen looks ready to burst with the confined fat. Plainly, he's a man who's not taking enough exercise. He remains within doors constantly. He eats and works, eats and works, works and eats. Dominic, as well as the Bodleon, I also came across a very exciting website which lists America's fattest presidents. Right. Cleveland is. second on the list after William Howard Taft, who everyone knows it's the fattest. Yeah, Taff got stuck in the bath, I think. He was so fat. Yes. It has a brilliant quote from him talking about exercise, and he says that bodily movement alone is among the dreary and unsatisfying things
现在，他们之所以邀请他这个局外人，是因为纽约州的党派和许多其他政党一样，内部派系斗争激烈。所以，克利夫兰参选了。共和党人自己在各个派系之间也分裂严重。所以他赢得了许多跨党派的共和党选票。他在1883年1月宣誓就职，成为纽约州州长，他说：“这一切都将关乎能力、效率和清廉的政府。”每个人都说：“哦，这太棒了。”克利夫兰作为政治候选人唯一的缺点在于，他这些年来一直在猛吃香肠。所以他现在胖得惊人。他现在有20英石重（约合280磅）。一位纽约记者曾写道：他的皮肤挂在面颊上，形成厚重、看起来不健康的褶肉。扣在他硕大胸腹上的外套看起来随时会因被束缚的脂肪而撑破。显而易见，这是一个缺乏运动的人。他整天呆在室内。他吃东西然后工作，工作然后吃东西，吃东西然后工作。多米尼克，除了博德利图书馆，我还偶然发现了一个非常令人兴奋的网站，上面列出了美国最胖的总统。没错。克利夫兰名列第二，仅次于威廉·霍华德·塔夫特，大家都知道他是最胖的。是的，塔夫特好像曾卡在浴缸里。他太胖了。是的。上面有一句他关于运动的精彩名言，他说：“单纯的身体运动是生命中最单调乏味且令人不满的事情之一。”
of life. Wow. He wouldn't fit in in your cricket team. No, he wouldn't. Not my gym. Although he might enjoy the standing around aimlessly element of playing cricket. I think he'd enjoy the tea. Yeah, exactly. So, in a TV age, this would be an issue. Chris Christy found this out. He was the governor of New Jersey, a very large man. Yeah. Sopranes, look. Yeah. But in a pre-TV age, you can be as fat as you like. It doesn't matter. What matters is his image of incorruptible competence. So 1884 is a presidential election year. The Republican Party, which is the dominant party, they've won every election since 1860, but now they're in a real mess. Basically, the Republican who had won last time was a guy called James A. Garfield. He was assassinated
哇。他可不适合进你的板球队。不，他进不了。尽管他可能会喜欢板球运动中漫无目的站着的那部分。我想他会很享受茶歇时间的。是的，完全如此。所以，在电视时代，体型会是个大问题。克里斯·克里斯蒂就发现了这一点。他是新泽西州长，一个身材非常魁梧的人。黑道家族，看。但在前电视时代，你想长多胖都可以。这根本不重要。重要的是他那不可动摇的能力形象。所以1884年是总统大选年。主导政党共和党自1860年以来赢得了每一次大选，但现在他们陷入了一团乱麻。基本上，上一次赢得大选的共和党人是一个叫詹姆斯·A·加菲尔德的人。他在仅仅上任几个月后，就被一个失望的求职者查尔斯·吉托暗杀了。所以加菲尔德遇刺身亡。
after just a few months by a disappointed office seeker called Charles Gito. So Garfield was assassinated. He was succeeded by his vice president, Chester Arthur. He's probably the least famous of all American presidents. If you Google him, you'll see massive whiskers, proper 19th century whiskers. Good. Arthur's administration had been blighted by a Republican feuding, different factions called the half-breeds and the stalwarts,
接替他的是他的副总统切斯特·阿瑟。他可能是所有美国总统中最不出名的一位。如果你在谷歌上搜索他，你会看到巨大的络腮胡，地道的19世纪风格的胡须。不错。阿瑟的政府因共和党内部派系斗争而饱受诟病，不同派系被称为“半血派”和“铁杆派”，
fighting over corruption and patronage. Now, an interesting Chester Arthur fact for you, by the way. I read, he owned 80 pairs of pants. And pants? Is that American English or proper English? I'm guessing Americans mean trousers. I think that's too many pairs of trousers. I think it's too many pairs of pants, frankly.
为了腐败和官职分配争斗不休。顺便给你讲个关于切斯特·阿瑟的有趣事实。我读到过，他拥有80条裤子（pants）。裤子？这是美式英语还是正宗英语？我猜美国人指的是长裤（trousers）。我觉得裤子的数量太多了。坦白讲，我觉得拥有这么多条裤子实在有点夸张。
He sounds great. I'd vote for him. What more do you want? But that's not enough. It's not enough. And the Republicans have actually dumped him as their candidate, and they've nominated a former Secretary of State, a guy from Maine called James G. Blaine.
他听起来挺棒的。我会投他一票。你还想要什么？但这还不够。这远远不够。而且共和党人实际上已经抛弃了他作为他们的候选人，转而提名了一位前国务卿、一个来自缅因州的人，名叫詹姆斯·G·布莱恩。
James G. Blaine. He's from Maine. Now, how familiar are you with James G. Blaine? May I ask? Love him. Because no one's heard of James G. Blaine now. But James G. Blaine at the time was massive. Like, James G. Blaine was a massive star. But not literally massive. Not in the Grave of Cleveland sense. No, not in the Cleveland or Taftsense.
詹姆斯·G·布莱恩。他来自缅因州。现在，你对詹姆斯·G·布莱恩了解多少？我可以问问吗？我太爱他了。因为现在根本没人听说过詹姆斯·G·布莱恩了。但当时的詹姆斯·G·布莱恩名气极大。就像，詹姆斯·G·布莱恩是个超级大明星。但并不是字面意义上的大块头。不是格罗弗·克利夫兰那种意义上的。不，不是克利夫兰或塔夫特那种体型。
But, well, he had a gigantic bit. He looks, if you Google him, He looks absolutely like an AI-generated, Gilded Age, American politician with a beard. However, at the time, he was a great speaker, he was very charming, he was a big star. His one great weakness was he had a reputation for corruption. But didn't everybody in this period? Yes, well, this is the thing.
但是，嗯，他有一把巨大的胡子。如果你在谷歌上搜索他，他看起来完全就像一个AI生成的、镀金时代的、留着胡子的美国政客。然而在当时，他是一位伟大的演说家，极具魅力，是个超级巨星。他唯一的致命弱点是名声不太好，卷入了腐败丑闻。但这个时期谁不这样呢？是的，没错，就是这样。
He was accused of having taken bribes from railroad companies. I mean, that's even more standard, right? I mean, it just comes with the territory. Yeah, everybody did this. However, he couldn't shake this. So the Democrats think, well, we've got a really good chance now. of winning the White House. Now, we can't win with the Southerner
他被指控收受铁路公司的贿赂。我的意思是，这甚至更标准了，对吧？我的意思是，这本来就是这行的常态。是的，每个人都这么干。然而，他始终无法摆脱这个污点。所以民主党人认为，好吧，我们现在有非常好的机会
because memories of the Civil War are still too raw. So we need someone from a northern state and someone who's squeaky clean is not corrupt. It's not like James G. Blaine. So they nominate Cleveland. Even though he's pretty untested
入主白宫。现在，我们不能推选南方人，因为对内战的记忆仍然历历在目。所以我们需要一个来自北方州的人，一个清清白白、没有腐败劣迹的人。不像詹姆斯·G·布莱恩那样。于是他们提名了克利夫兰。尽管他经历尚浅，
and he's only recently become governor of New York, they nominate him on the 11th of July 1884. Scenes of tremendous excitement. And dominate, presumably, a complete lack of background checks. A complete lack of background checks, exactly. Now, just 11 days after they nominate him, there comes an absolute bombshell because all this time, while the Democrats have been preparing to nominate Cleveland, a bloke called George H. Ball, who's a Baptist minister in Buffalo, has been getting very agitated.
而且不久前才刚当选纽约州州长，他们在1884年7月11日正式提名了他。现场群情激昂。多米尼克，想必他们完全没有做背景调查。完全没有做背景调查，正是如此。现在，就在他们提名他仅仅11天之后，发生了一个绝对重磅的炸弹事件，因为一直以来，当民主党人准备提名克利夫兰时，布法罗的一位名叫乔治·H·鲍尔的浸信会牧师一直感到非常焦虑。
George H. Baud is a very keen Republican. He'd been a delegate to the very first Republican convention in 1856. He hates the thought of a Democrat winning the presidency for the first time since the Civil War. And he has been writing letters to newspaper editors saying, don't endorse Cleveland. I know things about Cleveland that would make your eyes water. So, for example, there is this letter to the Chicago Advance. Tom, would you like to read the letter since you joining your American voice? I feel moved to warn you against saying much to the credit of Grover Cleveland. He is a libertine. No Christian should condone his crimes so far as to commend his candidacy.
乔治·H·鲍尔是个狂热的共和党人。他曾是1856年第一届共和党全国代表大会的代表。他极其痛恨自内战以来民主党人首次赢得总统宝座。他一直在给报纸编辑写信，说：“不要支持克利夫兰。我知道一些关于克利夫兰的事，说出来能让你们惊掉下巴。”比如，这是写给《芝加哥先驱报》的一封信。汤姆，既然你带有美式口音，你想读读这封信吗？我感到有必要警告你们，不要对格罗弗·克利夫兰大加赞赏。他是个放荡不羁之徒。任何基督徒都不应该纵容他的罪行，更不该去推荐他的候选资格。
About seven years ago, he seduced the head of the cloak department of Flint and Kent's leading merchants here. He kidnapped the woman after the boy was born, sent her to the insane asylum, and took the child from her. She escaped, finally settled, and gave up the child for $500. This, I know, to be true. I mean, that's quite an accusation. It's a heck of an accusation. Now, the advance didn't print this, the show of advance, but through sort of intermediaries, they showed it to the Republican candidate, James G. Blaine.
大约七年前，他诱奸了我们这里领先商人弗林特和肯特公司的斗篷部主管。在男孩出生后，他绑架了这个女人，把她送到疯人院，并夺走了她的孩子。她逃了出来，最终达成妥协，并以500美元的价格放弃了孩子。这件事，我确信是真的。我的意思是，这真是个重磅指控。这绝对是个惊天指控。现在，《先驱报》并没有刊登这封信，也就是《芝加哥先驱报》，但通过一些中间人，他们把信拿给共和党候选人詹姆斯·G·布莱恩看。
Blaine gave it to a mate at the Boston Journal, but they didn't run the story. They were very close to Blaine. It looked too obvious to be coming from them. So they feel that if they run it, I mean, what are they worried about, that it sounds fake? Yeah, it sounds fake. Right. That's their instinct. Well, not that it sounds fake that it's definitely untrue, but that they are so much in
布莱恩把信转交给《波士顿日报》的一个朋友，但他们没有刊登这个故事。他们跟布莱恩走得太近了。这看起来太明显是来自他们阵营的了。所以他们觉得如果他们刊登的话——我的意思是，他们在担心什么，担心这听起来像是伪造的吗？对，听起来像是假的。好吧。这才是他们的直觉。嗯，不是觉得听起来假到肯定是假的，而是觉得他们跟
they're so close to Blaine and the Republicans that it looks like naked propaganda. Right, okay. They're basically better coming from another source. So the source that breaks the story in the 21st of July is the Buffalo Evening Telegraph that we began with.
布莱恩和共和党人走得太近，刊登出来看起来就像赤裸裸的政治宣传。好吧，明白了。他们觉得由其他渠道爆料效果更好。因此，在7月21日爆料这个故事的正是我们开头提到的《布法罗晚报》。
That story, terrible tale, a dark chapter in a public man's history. And the story is as follows. The paper says, look, Grover Cleveland's not just a libertine. He's a really bad man.
那个故事标题是：可怕的故事，公职人物历史上的黑暗一页。故事内容如下。报纸上说：“看，格罗弗·克利夫兰不仅是个放荡的人。他是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。
He's a beastly drunk. he's a hypocrite and a lecher. He's always getting into brawls and saloons. He freely associates openly with lewd women. In other words, he is Harry Flashman, basically. He's even got the moustache. And there was more. There's this extraordinary story of lust and deceit. And this is the business about Maria Halpin. Now, I'll just summarize the story before we go to the break. Maria Halpin was a New Yorker. She'd been born around the same time as Cleveland, late 1830s. She had married a man from Worcester, England, an engraver. But he died of TB. She had two kids. So she moved to Buffalo. And as we've heard, she worked in the cloak department of Flint and Kent, this department
他是个嗜酒如命的野兽，是个伪君子和色狼。他总是卷入酒吧的斗殴。他公开与不三不四的女人来往。换句话说，他基本上就是哈里·弗莱什曼。他甚至连胡子都一样。”而且还有更多爆料。这是一个关于欲望和欺骗的离奇故事。这就是关于玛丽亚·哈尔平的事情。现在，在进入中场休息之前，我先总结一下这个故事。玛丽亚·哈尔平是纽约人。她和克利夫兰差不多在同一时期出生，即19世纪30年代末。她曾嫁给一个来自英国伍斯特的雕刻师。但他死于肺结核。她有两个孩子。所以她搬到了布法罗。正如我们所听到的，她在百货公司弗林特和肯特公司的斗篷部工作。根据她自己的说法，格罗弗·克利夫兰在百货公司注意到了她，对她很有好感。他当时是治安官。他追求过她。她打听了一下，发现他是个正派人。于是他们偶尔会见面。一切都非常得体。但根据《布法罗晚报》最初这篇报道的说法，最终克利夫兰诱奸了她。她发现自己怀孕了。他答应娶她，但随后基本上彻底人间蒸发，断绝了来往。在经过一番拉扯和沟通后，她给他发了消息，他最终表示愿意——引用原文——“承认自己的过错”，并会为她提供经济支持。但他特别补充说，根据这篇报道的说法，
store. Now, by her own account, Grover Cleveland saw her at this department store, was very taken with her. He was the sheriff in those days. He sort of courted her. She made inquiries. She found out that he was a decent person. So they would occasionally meet. And it was all very decorous. But according to this first story in the Buffalo Evening Telegraph, eventually Cleveland seduced her. She found out she was pregnant. He promised to marry her, but then he basically ghosted her completely, broke off relations. After a lot of towing and throwing, she sent messages to him, and he finally said he would, quote, acknowledge his fault, and he would make financial provision for her. But he made a point of adding, apparently, according to this story,
“我无法确定我就是孩子的父亲。你跟别的男人来往过。我怎么能确信那是我的孩子呢？”我能问你一下吗，因为这里似乎存在一个巨大的矛盾。是的。一方面，玛丽亚打听后发现克利夫兰声誉正派。正是这一点说服她接受了他的追求。
I can't be sure I'm the father. You've been seeing other men. How can I be certain as mine? Can I just ask you, because again, there seems a massive contradiction here. Yeah. That on the one hand, Maria is making inquiries and finds out that Cleveland is of a decent reputation. And that's what persuades her to accept his opportunities.
是的。另一方面，声称他声名狼藉，经常在酒吧里被捕之类的事。我的意思是，这两种说法该怎么调和？难道有他被捕的警察记录吗？我认为这是一个合理的评论。这是一个非常公平的评论，汤姆。
Yeah. On the other hand, the claim is that he's notorious and he's always being arrested in bars and things. Yes. I mean, how are those two claims to be squared? Are there police records of him being arrested? I think this is a fair comment. This is a very fair comment, Tom.
是的。另一方面，有说法称他声名狼藉，总是在酒吧等地被捕。是的。我的意思是，这两种说法该如何调和？有他被捕的警方记录吗？我认为这是一个合理的评论。这是一个非常合理的评论，汤姆。
And I will just say that the stuff with him, like, in ludicrous bar fights with kind of, you know, brothel madams or whatever, like smashing chairs over people's heads and stuff, I think it's, I don't think any sane person believes that these stories are true. Because everything we know of him in his legal group is he just worked. When he wasn't eating sausages and playing poker, he was just working all the time. Because presumably, as is claimed, everyone in Buffalo knows that he's his reprobate, it would be very easy to find... Of course. Would they have then elected him, mayor of Buffalo? That's the question. Yeah, so I'm just asking. Yeah, it's fair to ask these questions. Anyway, let's go back to Maria's story. Maria gave birth to a son on the 14th of September 1874. She's unmarried, of course. She's a widow, but at this point she's unmarried. She called the baby Oscar Folsom Cleveland.
我要说的是，关于他的那些事，比如在那种乱糟糟的酒吧里和老鸨之类的人发生冲突，比如把椅子砸在别人头上之类的，我觉得——我认为任何神智正常的人都不会相信这些故事是真的。因为从我们所了解的他在律师同业中的情况来看，他只是一直在工作。当他不吃香肠、不玩扑克的时候，他就是在没日没夜地工作。因为据推测，正如人们所声称的那样，水牛城的每个人都知道他是个浪荡子，要是真有这事，要找出来易如反掌……当然。难道他们当时还会选他当水牛城市长吗？这才是问题所在。对啊，我只是问问。好吧，问这些问题很合理。不管怎样，我们回到玛丽亚的故事上来。玛丽亚在1874年9月14日生下一个儿子。她当然未婚。她是个寡妇，但当时她并未婚配。她给这个男孩取名叫奥斯卡·福尔索姆·克利夫兰。
So the best friend. The best friend and Cleveland's surname. Seems a bit strange. Then something stranger happens. Her doctor, who was called James E. King, persuaded her to give him the baby. And he took it to his sister-in-law who's called Minnie Kendall, who lived with her husband by the Buffalo Stockyards. He said to Minnie, here is this baby. I want you to call it Jack.
也就是最好的朋友。最好的朋友的名字加上克利夫兰的姓氏。听起来有点奇怪。接着，更奇怪的事情发生了。她的医生名叫詹姆斯·E·金，说服她把孩子交给自己。他把孩子带给了自己的小姨子米妮·肯德尔，米妮和丈夫住在水牛城的牲口场附近。他对米妮说，这个孩子给你。我希望你叫他杰克。
I don't want you to tell anybody about it. I will pay you to be its carer and its wet nurse if you tell anyone there could be tragic consequences. So this is very mysterious. Then a few weeks later, Dr. King returned to the house and he said to his sister and nor Minnie, we need to go on a trip downtown with the baby. They went on this trip and they arrived at Bass, Cleveland and Bissell,
我不想让你把这事告诉任何人。我会付钱请你抚养他并做他的奶妈，如果你告诉任何人，可能会有悲惨的后果。所以这非常神秘。然后几个星期后，金医生回到房子里，对他的小姨子米妮说，我们需要带着孩子去市区一趟。他们去了市中心，来到了巴斯、克利夫兰暨比塞尔律所，
Cleveland's law firm. And they went in and in there is Grover Cleveland and a woman in floods of tears. The baby was asleep. The woman snatches the baby and she says, oh my baby, open your eyes, let me see them. Oh, my precious baby, why don't you open your eyes? Now, this is clearly Maria Halpin, the baby's mother.
也就是克利夫兰的律师事务所。他们走了进去，里面坐着格罗弗·克利夫兰和一个泪流满面的女人。孩子当时正在睡觉。那个女人一把抢过孩子，说道：哦，我的宝贝，睁开眼睛让我看看。哦，我宝贵的宝贝，你怎么不睁开眼睛呢？现在，这显然就是玛丽亚·海尔平，孩子的母亲。
According to the story, Cleveland roughly intervenes, says, give the baby back. Then he winks at the doctor. He lights a cigar and then Minnie and the baby are shown back out again. Now, all this, by the way, comes from an interview with Minnie Kendall that was in the Chicago Tribune. Dominic, can I just ask? Is the Chicago Tribune, which party is it supporting? It's a Republican paper.
根据这个故事，克利夫兰粗暴地介入，说，把孩子还回来。然后他向医生使了个眼色。他点燃一支雪茄，随后米妮和孩子就被赶了出来。顺便说一句，所有这些都源于《芝加哥论坛报》对米妮·肯德尔的一次采访。多米尼克，我可以问一下吗？《芝加哥论坛报》，它支持哪个党派？这是一份共和党报纸。
Right, okay. But if we want to check this out, there's a book by a guy called Charles Lackman, A Secret Life, The Lies and Scandals of President Grover Cleveland. You can tell what's sign he's on, which goes into this in great detail. So the months passed. Then in 1875, Dr. King comes back to C. Minnie, and he says, I need to take Jack back to his mother now. And this time, they go to Maria Halpin's boarding house.
对，好吧。但如果我们想查证此事，有一个叫查尔斯·拉克曼的人写过一本书，叫《秘密生活：总统格罗弗·克利夫兰的谎言与丑闻》。你可以看出他站在哪一边，这本书对此进行了非常详细的描述。于是几个月过去了。到了1875年，金医生回来找米妮，说，我现在得把杰克带回他母亲身边了。这一次，他们去了玛丽亚·海尔平的寄宿公寓。
Again, she's weeping. She's hysterical. They hand over the baby. And at this point, Maria Helpin absolutely loses it. She says to Dr. King, you're in league with Grover Cleveland. You've stolen my baby. You're evil men. Now, Minnie, who's been looking after the baby, is very shaken by all this.
她再次痛哭流涕。她歇斯底里。他们交出了孩子。就在这时，玛丽亚·海尔平彻底崩溃了。她对金医生说，你和格罗弗·克利夫兰是一伙的。你偷走了我的孩子。你们这些恶魔。现在，一直照顾孩子的米妮被这一切吓得不轻。
Dr. King says to her, as they leave, never speak of this again, Minnie. He says, I think it would be best for you and your husband to get out of town. I'll find new jobs for you. And indeed, they do get out of town. They end up moving to New Hampshire. And they disappear from this story. So, Maria has now got her son back, but the story now takes another melodramatic twist. She's got this baby back, but all the time she's appealing to Grover Cleveland to marry her, and he refuses.
金医生在离开时对她说，米妮，永远不要再提这件事了。他说，我想你和你的丈夫离开这个镇子是最好的选择。我会为你们找新的工作。事实上，他们也确实离开了镇子。他们最终搬到了新罕布什尔州。从此他们在故事里消失了。所以，玛丽亚现在找回了儿子，但故事却发生了又一个戏剧性的转折。她虽然找回了这个孩子，但她一直在恳求格罗弗·克利夫兰娶她，而他拒绝了。
She starts drinking heavily because she's so stressed, and that gives Cleveland his opportunity. In early 1876, Cleveland sends a friend with an offer. He says, I will give you the money to set up your own dress shop at Niagara Falls, but in return, you have to give me the baby, Oscar, and I will put him in the orphan asylum, and I will pay $5 a week for his bored and lodging. And Maria is desperate, she is distra, and under pressure, she agrees. So she goes off to Niagara, and two and a half-year-old Oscar goes off to the orphanage. But pretty much as soon as Maria gets to Niagara, she changes her mind. She says, no, I can't be separated from Oscar. She comes back to Buffalo. She goes straight to the
由于压力过大，她开始借酒浇愁，这给了克利夫兰机会。1876年初，克利夫兰派了个朋友带着一个提议去找她。他说，我会给你提供资金，在尼亚加拉瀑布开一家你自己的服装店，但作为交换，你必须把孩子奥斯卡交给我，我会把他送到孤儿院，并支付每周5美元的伙食和住宿费。玛丽亚走投无路，她心急如焚，在压力之下，她同意了。于是她动身去了尼亚加拉，两岁半的奥斯卡则被送去了孤儿院。然而玛丽亚一到尼亚加拉，几乎立刻就反悔了。她说，不，我不能和奥斯卡骨肉分离。她回到了水牛城。她径直前往
orphanage. She scoops up the baby and off she goes. And now comes the most shocking twist of all. If this story is true, this is the point to which Cleveland loses patience and comes to a very ruthless decision. Because a few weeks later, his confederate, this nefarious Dr. King, arrives a Maria's house with two policemen. They find her playing with Oscar. They drag her out, they drag her down the stairs, puts her in a carriage. They drive for just under an hour and they arrive this vast, sinister, institutional building. Oh, right. So this is where the woman in white,
孤儿院。她抱起孩子就走了。现在迎来了最令人震惊的转折。如果这个故事是真的，这就是克利夫兰失去耐心并做出极其冷酷决定的时刻。因为几个星期后，他的同伙、那个穷凶极恶的金医生带着两名警察来到了玛丽亚的家。他们发现她正和奥斯卡一起玩。他们把她拖出来，把她拖下楼梯，塞进一辆马车。他们驱车近一个小时，来到了一座巨大而阴森的机构大楼前。哦，原来如此。所以这就是白衣女人的地方，
the kind of classic melodramatic twist of the woman who gets locked up in a lunatic asylum. And according to the story, against her will, restrained by the policeman, Maria Halpin is registered as patient number 150 of the Providence lunatic asylum. Now, this is basically what happens to the heroin,
那种把人关进疯人院的经典情节。根据这个故事，在警察的强行压制下，玛丽亚·海尔平违背意愿，作为普罗维登斯疯人院的第150号病人被登记入院。这基本上就是女主角遭遇的命运，
isn't it? And the woman in white, Laura Fairly. But there was a difference. In real life, the people who run the Providence Lunatic Asylum are much more sort of decent, kindly and sensible. So they're not rattling keys on chains and things like that? They're not. Because the very next day, according to Maria's story, she goes to see the resident doctor who's called William Ring, and he examines her.
对吧？就像《白衣女人》里的劳拉·费尔利。但也有不同之处。在现实生活中，管理普罗维登斯疯人院的人要正派、善良和通情达理得多。所以他们不会晃动带锁链的钥匙之类的东西？他们不会。因为就在第二天，根据玛丽亚的说法，她去见了驻院医生威廉·林格，医生为她做了检查。
And he says, oh, my dear, you're not mad at all. We have no right to keep you here. You can come and go as you please. Really? That's not the impression I get from Wilkie Collins at all. No, exactly. But so a few days later, she walks out. to the asylum as a free woman. She goes to see a lawyer and she says, I want to get my son
医生说，哦，亲爱的，你根本没有发疯。我们无权把留你在这里。你想来就来，想走就走。真的吗？这跟我对威尔基·柯林斯的印象完全不一样。对，没错。但几天后，她就这样走出了
Oscar back. That's my priority. So the lawyer sets to work, but then a very strange thing, another very strange thing happens. Sometime later, Maria comes to see him again. He says, oh, the legal process is, you know, in train. It looks good. And she says, no, no, no, I've changed my mind. I don't want a scandal. I don't want to fight. And she hands him a letter. and it's a signed contract that she's just made with Grover Cleveland. She's given up all rights to her son forever, and in return, Cleveland has paid her $500. So she never did get Oscar back.
疯人院，成了一个自由人。她去找了一位律师，说，我想把我的儿子奥斯卡要回来。这是我的首要任务。于是律师开始着手处理，但接着发生了一件非常奇怪的事，又一件非常奇怪的事发生了。过了一段时间，玛丽亚再次来找他。律师说，哦，法律程序正在进行中。情况看起来不错。而她却说，不，不，不，我改变主意了。我不想要丑闻。我不想打官司。接着她递给他一封信，
And guess who Oscar was given to? The doctor, the sinister doctor. He was given to the sinister doctor. You've clearly read the notes. Well done. No. He's the only character who it could possibly be. I mean, it's not going to be Blaine or whatever his name is, is it?
那是她刚刚和格罗弗·克利夫兰签订的一份协议。她永远放弃了对儿子的所有权利，而作为交换，克利夫兰付给了她500美元。所以她最终还是没能把奥斯卡要回来。你猜奥斯卡被送给谁了？那个医生，那个阴险的医生。他被送给了那个阴险的医生。你显然读过资料。干得好。不。他是唯一一个可能的人选。我的意思是，总不可能是布莱恩或者别的什么名字吧？
He's the only other person you've mentioned. That's a twist. That would be unexpected. No, he was given to James E. King, the sinister doctor, whose only child had died two years earlier. And Oscar was given a new name, James E. King, Jr. And his mother never, ever saw the child again. Well, I guess that if this is breaking,
他除了你提到的那个人之外别无他人。这真是一个反转。那可真是出乎意料。不，他被送给了詹姆斯·E·金，那个阴险的医生，他的独生子在两年前夭折了。奥斯卡被赋予了一个新名字，小詹姆斯·E·金。他的母亲再也没有见过这个孩子。好吧，我想如果这个消息曝光的话，
then it's not excellent for Cleveland's campaign, is it? I mean, there are better things that could have happened. And I suppose the other question is, is this authentic or has it been fabricated by his political enemies? Are there elements of truth that have been kind of amplified? And I think the only thing to do is to have a break. And then when we come back, Dominic, perhaps you could reveal what you think happen. All right. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most?
那么对克利夫兰的竞选可没什么好处，对吧？我的意思是，本可以有更好的事情发生。我想另一个问题是，这是真实的，还是由他的政治敌人捏造的？其中是否包含被夸大的真实成分？我想现在唯一能做的就是休息一下。等我们回来后，多米尼克，也许你可以透露一下你认为发生了什么。好了。本集由优步为您赞助播出。话说，你是否体验过那种在你最需要的时候有人挺身而出的感觉？
We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you. show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by the week. You know, in medieval market squares, the town crier would bellow the news, loud, urgent, untested. Today, those criers have gone global. Scroll for five minutes and you get the same noise, only louder. Headlines pile up. Outrevellings. Out
我们有时都需要这种支持，优步深知这一点。优步不仅仅是一次行程或一份外卖，它代表着无论如何都会鼎力相助。就像你的异地朋友生病时送上一碗热汤，心情低落时送去一束鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么事，你都会挺身而出。心之所向，行之所往。优步，随叫随到。今天就下载应用程序吧。本集由《一周》杂志为您赞助。你知道吗，在中世纪的市场广场上，城镇传令官会大声宣读新闻，声音洪亮、十万火急、未经核实。如今，这些传令官已经走向全球。刷上五分钟手机，你听到的噪音如出一辙，只不过分贝更高。头条新闻堆积如山。耸人听闻的事情不断发酵，
rage builds, and yet somehow you feel none the wiser. That is where the week comes in. Award-winning editors read everything, sift the spin, and deliver to you what really matters, from left, from centre, from right. It's the historians method applied to the present. Multiple sources weighed together and set in context. The clutter is cut away. You can read it as a magazine with your coffee or as an app when you're on the move. And because it saves you hours of scrolling, you get that time back to do what really matters to you. Exclusively for Rest is History listeners,
愤怒情绪日益高涨，然而不知为何，你并未因此变得更有见识。《一周》杂志应运而生。屡获殊荣的编辑们阅读所有内容，过滤掉虚假宣传，为你呈现真正重要的事情——兼顾左翼、中间和右翼的视角。这就是应用于当下的历史学家方法。权衡多种信源并将其置于背景之中。剥离繁杂冗余的信息。你可以一边喝着咖啡阅读纸质杂志，也可以在出行时使用应用程序。由于它为你节省了数小时的刷手机时间，你可以把时间拿去做对你而言真正重要的事情。专属于《历史的沉淀》听众的福利：
six weeks free, then 10% off any subscription. Use the code history at theweek.com slash rest. That's history at theweek.com slash rest. Easy to cancel. No strings of. attached. Context, balance, perspective, the week, because the news needs a curator. During the Volvo Fall Experience event, discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that
免费订阅六周，之后任何订阅均可享受九折优惠。请在theweek.com/rest网站使用优惠码history。即history.com/rest。取消订阅十分简便。没有任何附加条件。提供背景、保持平衡、拓展视野，《一周》杂志——因为新闻需要一位策展人。在沃尔沃金秋体验季活动期间，探索非凡优惠与巧思设计，
leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute. This September, lease a 2026 X-E-90 plug-in hybrid from $599 bi-weekly at 3.99% during the Volvo Fall Experience event. Conditions supply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to explorevolvo.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and Dominic. This is an episode that could be about shocking political scandal or it could be about a wholly invented melodrama or it could be a mingling of both. I'm intrigued to find out what you think is going on here. Well, let's go back to the narrative in 1884. So remember, we're in July 1884.
为秋日出游预留充足空间。亲身体验沃尔沃传奇般的安全性能，为每一个清爽的早晨通勤带来内心安宁。今年9月，在沃尔沃金秋体验季期间，租赁一辆2026款XC90插电式混合动力车，双周租金仅需599美元起，利率低至3.99%。受条款约束，请访问您当地的沃尔沃经销商或登录explorevolvo.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的沉淀》，我是多米尼克。这一集的主题可能是一个令人震惊的政治丑闻，也可能是一个完全虚构的情节剧，或者两者兼而有之。我很想知道你觉得这背后到底是怎么回事。好吧，让我们回到1884年的历史叙事中。记住，我们现在身处1884年7月。
The Buffalo Evening Telegraph has just broken this story about Maria Halpin and Grover Cleveland. The presidential election is in tumult. The Democrats are in a complete panic. Cleveland's team are obviously horrified by this. And one of them comes to him and says, what shall we do? Cleveland says simply, perhaps admirably, if you're on team, Grover Cleveland, whatever you do, just tell the truth. But what is the truth?
《水牛城晚报》刚刚独家爆出了这桩关于玛丽亚·海尔平与格罗弗·克利夫兰的丑闻。总统大选正处于混乱之中。民主党人陷入了极度恐慌。克利夫兰的团队对此显然惊恐万状。其中一人来到他面前问，我们该怎么办？克利夫兰只是简单地、也许可以说是令人钦佩地回答说，如果你是格罗弗·克利夫兰团队的人，无论做什么，只要说实话就行。但真相究竟是什么？
They prepare a statement for him saying this story is a tissue of lies, complete nonsense. The child is not mine. When he sees the statement, he says, no, we can't put that out because that's not entirely true. And actually what ends up happening is he doesn't really make any public statement about the story at all. So the result of that is that in the next few days and weeks, the story spread. So within days, more than 100 newspapers have reprinted it.
他们为他准备了一份声明，称这个故事完全是谎言，纯属无稽之谈。这个孩子不是我的。当他看到这份声明时，他说，不，我们不能发表这个，因为这并非完全属实。事实上最终发生的情况是，他并没有就这个故事发表任何真正的公开声明。因此结果就是，在接下来的几天和几周里，这个故事传开了。几天之内，就有100多家报纸转载了它。
And at Republican rallies, people start chanting, Ma, Mar, where's my par? In other words, this is their venture loquising the abandoned child. I mean, it's interesting, isn't it? Because obviously now a scandal like this would just go completely viral in a matter of minutes. Yeah. But how long does it take to kind of pick up momentum in a pre-internet age? Oh, I think it actually is quite quick.
在共和党人的集会上，人们开始高喊：玛，玛，我的爸爸在哪里？换句话说，他们是在用这种方式来拟人化那个被抛弃的孩子。我的意思是，这很有趣，对吧？因为很明显，现在这样的丑闻在几分钟内就会在网络上彻底病毒式传播。是的。但在前互联网时代，这需要多长时间才能积聚势头呢？哦，我觉得其实挺快的。
I think other newspapers are reporting the story or reprinting bits of the story within, certainly within a week. Do they manage to track down Maria? Well, as we will see, there is a massive, massive feeding frenzy. People rushing to track down, not Maria, but anybody who knew her or anybody who knew Cleveland in Buffalo and so on and so forth. So yes. So where is she at this point? So she has moved elsewhere in New York State. I can't exactly remember where.
我觉得其他报纸在几天之内——当然在一周之内——就开始报道或转载这个故事的部分内容了。他们设法找到玛丽亚了吗？正如我们即将看到的，当时出现了一场狂热的媒体围猎。人们争先恐后地寻找的不是玛丽亚，而是任何认识她的人，或者任何在水牛城认识克利夫兰的人，诸如此类。所以是的。那么她当时在哪里呢？她已经搬到了纽约州的其他地方。我记不清具体是哪里了。
But she has been getting on with her life, I suppose. She's been living in relative obscurity. So she has left Buffalo and there's a race in the American media to be the person that tracks her down and finds her story in her own voice. Whether they ever do really do that, we will come on to, Tom. Anyway, one of Cleveland's supporters who is a judge, a Democratic New York judge called Horatio King, eventually comes out with a statement. He says, look, the governor asked me to go to Buffalo to look into. this matter. I have looked into this matter. This is the truth. He says a few years ago, the governor was, and I quote, sowing his wild oats. He met this woman and became intimate with
但我想她一直在过着自己的生活。她一直在默默无闻地生活。所以她已经离开了水牛城，美国媒体展开了一场竞赛，争当第一个找到她并以她本人的声音还原故事真相的人。汤姆，至于他们是否真的做到了这一点，我们稍后再谈。无论如何，克利夫兰的一位支持者、一位名叫霍雷肖·金的纽约民主党法官最终发表了一份声明。他说，看，州长让我去水牛城调查这件事。我已经调查过了。这就是真相。他说，几年前，州长曾——我引用原话——“播撒轻狂的种子”。他遇到了这个女人，并与她
her. She was a widow and not a good woman by any means. Very gallant. Yes. Mr. Cleveland, hearing this, began to make inquiries and discovered that two of his friends were intimate with her at the same time as himself. Again, not exactly the height of chivalry. And Dominic, can I just ask, This guy is called King. Is he any relation to the doctor, King? No, he's not. No, that's just a coincidence. Nothing to do with it.
有了亲密关系。她是个寡妇，绝不是什么好女人。真是充满骑士风度。是的。克利夫兰先生听到这些后，开始四处打听，发现他的两个朋友和他在同一时期也与她有染。同样，这算不上什么绅士风度。多米尼克，请问一下，这个人叫金。他和那个金医生有什么亲戚关系吗？不，没有。不，这只是巧合。毫无关系。
So this guy, Horatio King, says, Cleveland was intimate with this woman, but he was not the father. The father was one of these friends of his who was married with a daughter. So Cleveland decided very generously to cover for him. I quote,
所以这个人，霍雷肖·金，声称克利夫兰确实和这个女人有亲密关系，但他不是孩子的父亲。父亲是他的一个已婚且有女儿的朋友。所以克利夫兰非常慷慨地决定为朋友顶包。我引用原话：
he took care of the child and mother like a man and did everything in his power for them until the woman became a confirmed victim. him of alcoholism. He never separated the mother and child, nor did he do anything to injure the woman. He was throughout the affair a victim of circumstances. He accepted responsibilities that not one man in a thousand has shouldered, and he acted honorably in the matter. So, this is an alternative version of the story. Cleveland did have relations with Maria Halpin, but was not the father. And was the father supposedly the best friend?
他像个真正的男子汉一样照顾着孩子和母亲，竭尽所能地帮助他们，直到这个女人成了酒精中毒的
Well, this is the implication, isn't it? That it certainly could be. best friend, exactly. Now, at this point, there's a massive media-feeding frenzy. The Republican papers are competing to denounce Cleveland as an absolute debauchy and a libertine. The Democrat papers paint Maria as a mad woman and as a hussy, that's sort of a scarlet woman. The Boston Globe, for example, said, Mrs. Halpin is evidently in epileptic. They claimed they tracked her down and had found her. She has every symptom of insanity. Her eyes are glasses. She can't look her question her in the face. She has trembling, twitching. and sudden starts at every unexpected noise peculiar to insane persons.
受害者。他从未将母子分离，也没有做过任何伤害这个女人的事。在这场风波中，他自始至终都是环境的牺牲品。他承担了一千个人里也未必有一个人敢于承担的责任，他在这件事上表现得无可挑剔。所以，这是故事的另一个版本。克利夫兰确实与玛丽亚·海尔平有染，但不是孩子的父亲。而且所谓的父亲就是那个最好的朋友？这就是暗示，对吧？绝对有这个可能。就是最好的朋友，没错。此时此刻，一场大规模的媒体狂欢正在上演。共和党报纸竞相谴责克利夫兰是个彻底的堕落分子和放荡者。民主党报纸则把玛丽亚描绘成一个疯女人和轻浮女子，也就是某种荡妇。例如，《波士顿环球报》就声称，海尔平太太显然是个癫痫患者。他们声称找到了她并采访到了她。她表现出所有精神错乱的症状。她的眼神游移不定。她不敢直视提问者。她浑身发抖、抽搐，
Now, the problem with all this, the reason I'm being slightly evasive about have they tracked her down or not, is at this point, so the 1880s, it is very common for newspapers to invent stories out of thin air and to fabricate quotes. So the Globe has her saying, despite the fact they say she's mad, they then say she has nothing but praise for Grover Cleveland. I hope Mr. Cleveland will be elected.
每听到意料之外的声响就会突然惊悸，这些都是精神病患者特有的表现。所有这一切的问题在于——我之所以对他们是否真的找到她态度有些含糊——是因为在当时，也就是19世纪80年代，报纸凭空捏造故事和伪造引语是非常普遍的现象。《环球报》甚至援引了她的话，尽管他们之前说她疯了，但他们接着又说她对格罗弗·克利夫兰赞不绝口。我希望克利夫兰先生能当选。
He's a good plane on. honest, man, who has always been friendly to me and used me kindly. It's a shame that newspapers should have issued such lies. So this is presumably a Democrat supporting newspaper. Of course it is. I don't think she ever spoke to the Boston Globe, actually. And the fact that the newspapers are falling into line, you know, that leads us quite nicely to how this changes or doesn't change the presidential race. Because we already mentioned the sex scandal in the 1990s, the Clinton Lewinsky sex scandal. And of course, there are lots of sex scandal. And of course, there are lots of sex scandals in, for example, the 2016 presidential election.
他是个正直、诚实的人，对一直我都非常友好，待我也很好。报纸竟然散布这样的谎言，真是太可耻了。所以这显然是一份支持民主党的报纸。当然是的。其实我觉得她根本就没跟《波士顿环球报》说过话。而报纸纷纷站队的现象，这非常巧妙地引出了这件事如何改变或未曾改变总统竞选。因为我们之前提到过20世纪90年代的性丑闻，即克林顿与莱温斯基的性丑闻。当然，还有很多其他的性丑闻，例如2016年的总统大选。
And what I would say all these things have in common is they don't change people's minds at all. People simply divide on party lines. And they did this in 1884. And it is a very famous example. Now, there's always anything to do with America in the 19th century. There's always a Mark Twain quotation. And there actually is a Mark Twain quotation about this.
我要说的是，所有这些事情的共同点在于，它们根本无法改变人们的想法。人们只是按照党派划线。1884年也是如此。这是一个非常著名的例子。跟19世纪美国的任何事情一样，总少不了一句马克·吐温的名言。关于这件事，确实有一句马克·吐温的名言。
I think he last featured on the rest of history in our series on the Belgian Congo, didn't he? He did. Yeah. So this is slightly earlier Mark Twain. He was a lifelong Republican, but he's decided to break with them about corruption. He thinks Blaine is too corrupt, and he's going to vote for Cleveland. And Twain writes, he says, this story is absolute nonsense. And then he says, even if it isn't nonsense, yeah, who cares?
我想他上次在《历史的沉淀》中出场是在我们关于比属刚果的系列节目里，对吧？是的。所以这是马克·吐温稍早些时候的言论。他曾是一名坚定的共和党人，但由于腐败问题，他决定与他们决裂。他认为布莱恩太腐败了，并打算投票给克利夫兰。吐温写道，他说，这个故事完全是无稽之谈。然后他说，就算这不是无稽之谈，那又怎样，谁在乎呢？
Who cares if Cleveland slept with this woman? To see grown men, apparently in their right mind, seriously arguing against a bachelor's fitness for president because he had private intercourse with a consenting widow isn't human nature of the most consummate sham and lie that was ever invented. Do any of the papers, in your opinion, get to interview Maria? I mean, are there any substantiated interviews with her? Are they all made up?
谁在乎克利夫兰是不是跟这个女人睡过？看到一些成年人，明明看起来神智正常，却在严肃地争论一个单身汉是否有资格当总统，理由仅仅是他和一个自愿的寡妇发生过私生活，这简直是人类历史上最厚颜无耻、最虚伪透顶的假象和谎言。在你看来，有没有哪家报纸真正采访到了玛丽亚？我的意思是，有没有关于她的任何经过证实的采访？还是全都是编造出来的？
I mean, it seems very difficult to work out what's going on here. I would say, no, there's none that we can trust. There are more interviews to come, by the way, and there's another statement to come which might change your opinion of the case, Tom. and at that point you might change your mind, but I think we have to be really, really careful with any of them. Okay. So the weeks go by, the campaign is really, really intense.
我的意思是，要想弄清楚这到底是怎么回事似乎非常困难。我会说，没有，没有一件是我们可以信任的。顺便说一句，后面还会有更多的采访，而且还会有另一份声明，可能会改变你对这个案子的看法，汤姆。到了那个时候，你可能会改变想法，但我认为我们对所有这些说法都必须极其、极其谨慎。好吧。几周过去了，竞选非常、非常激烈。
It's obviously going to be very close. The big issues are, I mean, it's no one, no one cares about the Gilded Age because the issues might seem, some of this to be very dreary. They are civil service reform and tariffs. Oh, people love tariffs. So Blaine and the Republicans love tariffs at this point. So that hasn't changed.
这显然会是一场势均力敌的较量。核心议题是——我的意思是，没有人关心镀金时代，因为有些议题听起来可能非常乏味。它们是公务员制度改革和关税。哦，人们可太喜欢关税了。所以布莱恩和共和党人在此时非常热衷于关税。这一点倒是一直没变。
Right. Cleveland is a bit more of a free trader, but he keeps quiet about this or downplays it because he knows the American people in a very tariff-friendly mood. At the same time, the Republicans, because they know it's going to be close and they're going to lose the White House for the first time in a generation, they are going berserk what's called waving the bloody shirt, which means basically disinterring the corpses of the civil war. Right. So if the Democrats get in, then it's back to slavery. Well, they say basically Cleveland will, what would he do? he will stop paying pensions to veterans of the Union Army, and he'll pay reparations to former slaveholders in the South, both of which are completely untrue. And the most famous example, actually, is there's a Protestant minister who just a few
克利夫兰在自由贸易方面更倾向于开放一些，但他对此保持低调或淡化处理，因为他知道美国人民正处于非常支持关税的心态中。与此同时，共和党人因为知道选情胶着，且他们将在一代人中首次失去白宫，因而陷入了疯狂，也就是所谓的“挥动血衣”，这基本上就是把内战的尸骨重新挖出来。所以，如果民主党上台，那就意味着回到奴隶制。好吧，他们基本上宣称克利夫兰会——他会做什么呢？他会停止向联邦军队的老兵支付抚恤金，并向南方的原奴隶主支付赔偿金，这两者完全都是子虚乌有。其中最著名的例子其实是，有一位新教牧师在选举前仅几天发表了一次公开演讲，称民主党是“伏特加、罗马天主教和叛乱”之党，也就是说他们是一群酒鬼、天主教徒和南方邦联残余。所以这些都是很好的谩骂之词。但这些都没有真正起到作用，而且看起来克利夫兰很有可能会赢得大选。就在只剩四天的时候，又一颗重磅炸弹落下。10月31日，共和党报纸《芝加哥论坛报》发表了一份由玛丽亚·海尔平签署的宣誓书。她说，在这件事上我其实一直保持沉默。
days before the election makes a public speech saying that the Democrats of the Party of Rum, Romanism, and rebellion, i.e. they're drunks, they're Catholics, and their Confederates. So it's all good, sort of invective. But none of this really lands, and it's a lot of it looks as though Cleveland might just win. And then with just four days to go, there's another bombshell. On the 31st of October, the Chicago Tribune, Republican paper, publishes an affidavit signed by Maria Halpin. She says, I have actually kept quiet in all this.
你知道，这些归咎于我的话并不是真的。我一直保持沉默。当格罗弗·克利夫兰给我带来的痛苦在报纸上沸沸扬扬时，我一直低调隐忍。但现在我决定发声了。她说，格罗弗·克利夫兰绝对是我孩子的父亲，但我们关系的性质比任何人知道的都要黑暗。这就是真实的故事。1873年12月15日，也就是11年前，我在去参加一个生日派对的路上遇到了格罗弗·克利夫兰，他劝我去海洋之家餐厅和他一起吃晚餐。我们吃过晚饭后，他像以前许多次那样，把我送回了天鹅街的住处。
You know, these quotes attributed to me are not true. I've been keeping quiet. I've kept my head down while the suffering inflicted on me by Grover Cleveland has been in the papers. But now I've decided to speak up. She says, Glover Cleveland absolutely was the father of my child, but the nature of our relationship was darker than anybody knows. This is the true story. On the 15th of December, 1873, so 11 years ago, I was on my way to a birthday party when I met Grover Cleveland, and he persuaded me to go and have dinner with him at the Ocean House restaurant. We had dinner, and then he walked me home to
他把他送回了家。他跟她上了楼，然后，在我的房间里，他使用武力和暴力，在未经我同意的情况下，彻底摧毁了我。当他达到目的后，他告诉我，他下定决心要毁了我，哪怕花掉10000美元，或者为此被绞死也在所不惜。所以“摧毁”的意思就是强奸。所以“摧毁”的意思就是强奸。换句话说，没错，他强奸了她。现在，一些听众听到这里可能会说，哦，好吧，如果真是这样，为什么玛丽亚·海尔平当时不直接去报警呢？答案显而易见。今天一个女性要去报警都很困难。
my rooms and Swan Street, as he had done many times. He walked her home. He went to upstairs with her, and then, while in my rooms, he accomplished my ruin by the use of force and violence and without my consent. After he had accomplished his purpose, he told me that he was determined to ruin me if it cost him $10,000 or if he was hanged by the neck for it. So ruin, meaning rape. So ruin meaning rape. In other words, exactly, he raped her. Now, some listeners at this point might say, oh, well, if that's the case, why didn't Maria helping go to the police straight away? The answers are obvious. It's difficult for a woman to go to the police today.
在1873年就更是难上加难了，当时社会有一种先入为主的观念，认为一个正派的女性根本就不会落入那种境地。当时还有一种成见，认为只要女性愿意，她总是可以进行反抗的。而且玛丽亚当然知道，陪审团绝不会对她允许克利夫兰护送她回家并随她上楼这一事实抱有任何同情。如果她没有遭受袭击的直观证据，要在官司中胜诉——尤其是对手还曾是一位治安官——几乎是不可能的。现在，就竞选本身而言，许多听众可能会说，天哪，在总统竞选前四天爆出强奸指控，
It's even more difficult in 1873 when there's a presumption that an honorable woman would not be in that position. There was also a presumption that a woman could always resist if she wanted to. And Maria, of course, would have known that a jury would look very unkindly on the fact that she had allowed Cleveland to escort her home and then come upstairs with her. And that if she didn't have visible evidence of assault, it's very unlikely, especially against a former sheriff, that she would win the case. Now, just in terms of the campaign itself, a lot of listeners may say, well, my God, an allegation of rape four days before the presidential campaign,
这对于克利夫兰来说绝对是彻底完蛋了。但这些听众可能会震惊地听到，据我们所知，这在选举上完全没有产生任何影响，因为当选民前往投票站时，克利夫兰和布莱恩的得票率不相上下。克利夫兰获得48.8%的选票。布莱恩获得48.3%。这次选举实际上取决于东北部几个州（如纽约州和新泽西州）的一小部分选民，大约有2500人。而他们把票投给了克利夫兰，而不是布莱恩。于是，在经历了近30年之后，民主党重返白宫。现年47岁的克利夫兰也将成为美国历史上第二年轻的总统。现在，民主党人可以在那首共和党歌曲后面加上一句新的歌词了。
surely this must be curtains for Cleveland. But those listeners will perhaps be shocked to hear this has absolutely no electoral impact as far as we can tell, because when the voters go to the polls, Cleveland and Blaine are neck and neck. Cleveland gets 48.8%. Blaine, 48.3%. The election actually comes down to 2,500 voters across a handful of northeastern states, places like New York and New Jersey. And they go for Cleveland, not for Blaine. So after almost 30 years, the Democrats are back in the White House. And Cleveland, who's 47, will at this point be the second youngest president in American history. And so now the Democrats can add an extra line to that Republican song.
“玛，玛，我的爸爸在哪里？”他们现在不仅唱这首歌，还唱着：“已经去白宫啦。哈，哈，哈。”事实上，唯一的民主党人不高兴的人就是克利夫兰。他对自己赢得大选感到非常痛苦。他对一个朋友说：“我认为接下来的四年是对我祖国的一场可怕的、自我惩罚式的苦修。我在其中看不到任何乐趣，也找不到任何满足感。”所以情况就是这样。
Ma, Mar, where's my par? They now sing that song and they sing, gone to the White House. Ha, ha, ha. Actually, the only Democrat who isn't pleased is Cleveland. He's very miserable about having one. He said to a friend, I look upon the next four years as a dreadful self-inflicted penance for the good of my country. I can see no pleasure in it and no satisfaction. So there you go.
但是汤姆，我们的一些听众可能会想，好吧，谁在乎他怎么想呢？他是个强奸犯。他是个施暴者。你知道的，他是个可怕的恶魔。美国人怎么能把这样一个身上背负着此类指控的男人送进白宫呢？确实令人匪夷所思。好吧，让我们再次回顾她的故事，并回答其中的一些问题。克利夫兰的最新传记是由一个叫特洛伊·塞尼克的人写的。
But some of our listeners, Tom, may be thinking, well, I mean, who cares what he thinks? He's a rapist. He's an abuser. You know, he's a terrible villain. And how is it that Americans could put such a man with such allegations hanging over him into the White House? How indeed. Well, so let's have a look at her story again and answer some of those questions. The most recent biography of Cleveland is by a guy called Troy Seneca.
这本书名为《铁血男儿》（A Man of Iron），出版于2022年。他对这一切有一些有趣的看法。首先，他回答了你的问题，汤姆，关于资料来源的问题。他说，拜托，所有这些报纸都是党派色彩浓厚的共和党报纸。向他们提供信息的人乔治·鲍尔是一个狂热的共和党支持者。而玛丽亚自己的话总是通过共和党记者传达到我们这里。我们知道玛丽亚此时在哪里、在做些什么吗？她似乎在纽约州的各个地方隐蔽游荡，人们正试图
It's called A Man of Iron and it was published in 2022. And he has some interesting things to say about all this. So first of all, he answers your question, Tom, about the sources. He says, come on, all of these papers are partisan Republican papers. The person who's giving them the information, George Ball, is a fervent Republican supporter. And Maria's own words always come to us through Republican journalists. Do we know where Maria is at this point, what she's doing? She's sort of lurking around in New York State in various sort of, the people are trying
追踪她的下落。她——你知道的，有迹象表明她可能接受过零星的采访，她也确实签署过宣誓书，但她究竟有没有读过这些宣誓书则是另一回事。所以她一直在纽约的小城镇里刻意保持低调，躲避媒体。现在回到这些指控本身，其中有些显然是疯话。克利夫兰并不是一个——他虽然好饮两杯，但绝不是酒鬼。他不打架。他不跟妓女鬼混。
to sort of track her down. She, you know, there's some sense that she may have given the odd interview, where she's certainly signed affidavits, but whether she's read them is a different matter. So she's trying to keep her head down and escape the press in sort of small town, New York. Now, to go back to the allegations, some of them clearly are mad. Cleveland was not a, he liked your drink, but he's not a drunk. He doesn't get into fights. He doesn't hang around with prostitutes.
我的意思是，有一回，对了，那个叫乔治的人。乔治·鲍尔，那个牧师说，克利夫兰驾驶的马车轧死了他的朋友奥斯卡·福尔索姆。好吧，这可真是个反转。我的意思是，这完全是无稽之谈。话虽如此，特洛伊·塞尼克在他的传记中指出，克利夫兰显然认识这个女人。我的意思是，我认为他绝对认识她。他绝对追求过她。我认为他们发生过性关系的可能性非常大。
I mean, at one point, right, that guy, George. George Ball, the minister said, Cleveland drove the carriage that killed his friend, Oscar Folsom. Okay, well, that is a twist. I mean, that's totally untrue. All of that said, Troy Sennick in his biography, says, clearly Cleveland did know this woman. I mean, I think she definitely knew her. He definitely courted her. I think it's very probable that they slept together.
而且他可能就是她孩子的父亲。不过，让我们暂且保留这个想法，稍后再回过头来看。所以我觉得还有另一种可能。至于绑架孩子并把她关进疯人院的说法，这确实非常接近维多利亚时代的悬疑小说，不是吗？我的意思是，我们已经多次指出这一点，但有一种微妙的感觉，也许，如果你是一个读过大量威尔基·柯林斯作品的进取型记者，这正是你会编造出来的故事。特别是由于《白衣女人》中的大反派，他最显著的特征就是非常胖。是的。这也是格罗弗·克利夫兰最显著的特征。
And he may have been the father of her child. Although, let's just hold that thought and come back to it a little bit. So I think there's another possibility. As for the stuff about kidnapping the child and putting her in an asylum, it does seem very close to Victorian sensation fiction, doesn't it? I mean, we've made that point many times, but there's a slight sense, perhaps, that if you're an enterprising journalist who's read a lot of Wilkie Collins, this is the story you'd invent. And particularly because the villain of the woman in white, his salient feature is that he's very fat. Yes. And that's also the salient feature of Graver Cleveland.
所以也许这再次促使他们想出了那种充满情节剧色彩的转折。完全正确。让我们来看看其中的两个要素。首先是孤儿院。就连爆出这个故事的《水牛城电讯报》也承认玛丽亚·海尔平确实借酒浇愁。所以完全有可能的是，克利夫兰的朋友或城里的其他人抱走孩子并把它送到孤儿院，以为自己做的是正确的事。并且还有一些迹象表明玛丽亚曾对克利夫兰发出过死亡威胁。
So perhaps, again, it prompts them to come up with maybe that particular melodramatic spin. Exactly. And let's take two elements of that. First of all, the orphanage. Even the Buffalo Telegraph, which broke this story, admitted that Maria Halpin had been driven to drink. So it's perfectly possible that Cleveland's friends or people in the city might have taken the baby and put it in an orphanage thinking they were doing what was right. And there's also some suggestion that Maria had made death threats against Cleveland. Evelyn, and indeed said, I will take my own life and that of the baby.
甚至说过：“我要结束我自己的生命，还有这个孩子的命。”在这种情况下，也许这就说得通了。孩子因此被，可以说是送去接受照料。至于她被关进疯人院一事，我可能在讲述时带有一些倾向性，没有告诉你关于疯人院的全部真相。那家疯人院基本上——它不是维多利亚时代那种，你知道的，它不像济贫院。
In that case, maybe it is plausible. The baby would, as it were, be taken into care. As for her being locked up in the asylum, I've perhaps slightly loaded this by not telling you the whole truth about the asylum. The asylum is basically, it's not a Victorian sort of, you know, it's not like a workhouse. Manical or something. No, it's a charitable organisation run by Catholic nuns.
疯人院之类的吗？不，这是一个由天主教修女运营的慈善机构。按当时的标准来看，它相当开明。它不仅治疗精神病患者，还治疗酗酒者。
It was quite progressive by the standards of the day. It also treated alcoholics as well as. as people who were mentally ill. So in his book, Troy Seneca basically compares, says it's basically like a rehab center, like a sanatorium. And Maria, she wasn't locked up. She wasn't detained against her will.
所以特洛伊·塞尼克在他的书中基本上进行了对比，说它基本上就像一个戒毒所，一个疗养院。玛丽亚并没有被关起来。她没有被违背意愿地拘禁。
Actually, she stayed there almost a week. Seems to have stayed almost a week voluntarily before walking out as a free woman. And finally, the payoff, $500. I could see you were itching to ask how much $500 would be. $500 in relative income terms is about $160,000 today.
实际上，她在那里待了将近一周。似乎是自愿待了将近一周后，才作为自由人走了出来。最后是那笔500美元的赔偿金。我看得出来你很急着想知道500美元在当时相当于现在的多少钱。按相对收入水平计算，500美元大约相当于今天的16.6万美元。
So you may say still not enough to buy your child, as it were, but it's not... Not nothing. Exactly. Now, finally, we come to the most controversial element, the rape. A lot of listeners, I think, would say automatically you should believe the woman. And I completely understand why they'd say that. I suppose the question is, are we hearing a woman's words?
所以你可能会说，这仍然不足以用来“买”下你的孩子，但它并不是……并非一文不值。完全正确。现在，我们终于来到了最具争议的环节——强奸。我想很多听众会本能地认为应该相信女性，我完全理解他们为什么会这么说。我想问题在于，我们听到的是一个女性自己的话语，
Or are we hearing the words of a journalist? Exactly. Because which one would you believe? First of all, there's the Maria Halpin quoted in the Chicago Tribune, who says Cleveland accomplished my ruin by force and violence. But then there's a Maria Halpin quoted four days later in the Detroit Free Press who says, I was tricked into signing that statement under pressure. I never even read it. She says, it's all lies. There's no rape. I have no fault whatever to find in Mr. Cleveland. Now, the problem is that's in a Democrat newspaper. So one of these statements, is clearly untrue. But both could be. Or both could be. And what's worse? We know both sides were drafting statements for her to read and sign because the Republicans got hold of one prepared by the Democrats and leaked it and said, look at this. The Democrats are trying to force this poor woman to sign a statement. They were doing the same, of course. So we never actually get a sense of the real Maria Halper. We never hear her speak unmediated by partisan kind of intermediaries.
还是一个记者的话语？完全正确。因为你该相信哪一个呢？首先，《芝加哥论坛报》中引用的玛丽亚·海尔平说，克利夫兰通过武力和暴力摧毁了我。但随后在《底特律自由报》中，四天后引用的玛丽亚·海尔平却说，我是被诱骗在压力下签署那份声明的。我甚至根本没读过它。她说，这全都是谎言。根本没有强奸。我对克利夫兰先生没有任何意见。问题在于，那是发表在一家民主党报纸上的。所以其中有一份声明显然是不真实的。但两份都可能是假的。或者两份都可能是假的。更糟糕的是什么呢？我们知道双方都在为她起草供她阅读和签署的声明，因为共和党人拿到了一份由民主党人准备的声明并将其泄露出去，然后说：“看这个。民主党人正试图逼迫这个可怜的女人签署声明。”当然，共和党人也在做同样的事。所以我们永远无法真正了解真实的玛丽亚·海尔平。我们听到的永远不是她未经党派中间人过滤的真实心声。
So that's a big problem. Now, to go back, I said I'd leave one thing hanging, which was a possibility about the child. Come back to it. The child's name is so strange. Oscar Folsom, Cleveland. Oscar Folsom, his best friend and then Cleveland's surname. That would sort of make sense of Cleveland had chose it. But then, why would he put his own surname on the baby if he's trying to cover it up?
所以这是一个巨大的问题。现在回到刚才的话题，我说过我会留一个悬念，也就是关于孩子的可能性。我们再来看看。这个孩子的名字太奇怪了。奥斯卡·福尔索姆·克利夫兰。奥斯卡·福尔索姆，他最好的朋友，然后加上克利夫兰的姓氏。如果这是克利夫兰选择的，那倒还说得通。但是，如果他想掩盖真相，为什么要把自己的姓氏加在这个婴儿身上呢？
Because it's so obvious. Now, in the last days of the campaign, another Detroit paper says, said, quote, if the whole truth is ever told, it will show Cleveland has taken the part of an honorable man. This intimation involves the memory of a departed friend, a departed friend, Oscar Folsom. In other words, I think there's a strong possibility that Folsom was the father, that maybe they both slept with this woman. Cleveland did cover it up, did take the blame for it. When it came out, he was very angry because it's a slur on his friend, but also, he wants to protect Emma, the widow with whom he's very close, and her daughter, Francis, who is his legal ward. And where the truth lies in all this, it's impossible to tell. Now, some listeners may be thinking, yeah, but who's this bloke, Troy Sennick, who is covering for Cleveland? So which side of the political divide is he on? We're in a hall of mirrors once again, Tom. Because on the one hand, Troy Sennick used to be a speechwriter for George W. Bush. So a Republican. Yeah.
因为这太明显了。在竞选的最后几天，底特律的另一家报纸称，如果全部真相水落石出，它将表明克利夫兰表现得像个有荣誉感的人。这种暗示涉及一个已故朋友的记忆，这个已故的朋友就是奥斯卡·福尔索姆。换句话说，我认为有很大的可能性福尔索姆才是父亲，也许他们俩都跟这个女人睡过。克利夫兰确实帮忙掩盖了，也确实把责任揽了下来。当事情败露时，他非常愤怒，因为这玷污了他朋友的名声，而且他也想保护埃姆——那个与他关系密切的寡妇，以及她的女儿弗朗西斯（克利夫兰是她的法定监护人）。至于真相究竟如何，根本无法判断。现在，一些听众可能会想：是的，但这个叫特洛伊·塞尼克的家伙是谁？他是在为克利夫兰开脱吗？那他究竟站在政治分歧的哪一边呢？我们又一次走进了一座镜子迷宫，汤姆。因为一方面，特洛伊·塞尼克曾经是乔治·W·布什的演讲撰稿人。所以他是个共和党人。
So some people may say that shows terrible judgment to be writing speeches for George Shipley Bush. But so I googled Troy Sennick. And do you know what I found? I found his Twitter feed. And the very first thing I found on his Twitter feed, Tom, with these words, Tom Holland and Dominic Sambrick are treasures. And it is lovely for once to have an ultra popular podcast that you don't have to worry
所以有些人可能会说，为乔治·史蒂普利·布什写演讲稿简直是判断力极差。不过我谷歌了一下特洛伊·塞尼克。你知道我发现了什么吗？我找到了他的推特。我在他推特上看到的头一件事，汤姆，就是这些话：汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑布里克是无价之宝。难得能有一个超级受欢迎的播客，让你不用担心
will make society dumber. Wow. That's the revelation. What judgment. And what does he say has gone on? because whatever he says, I'm backing his opinion now. He says Cleveland has been framed by partisan Republicans, and the Cleveland was a tremendous fellow.
会把社会变蠢。哇。这就是灵感所在。这判断力。他觉得发生了什么？因为不管他说什么，我现在都支持他的观点。他说克利夫兰是被党派共和党人陷害的，克利夫兰是个了不起的家伙。
Okay, well, in that case, that's closed. And to be honest, he's not the only Cleveland biographer to make that case. So the canonical Cleveland biographer for a lot of the 20th century's guy called Alan Nevins, who was a massively distinguished professor at Columbia University, one of the Pulitzer Prize. He said this was pure Republican scandal mongering. And is this another of those vast American presidential barricableness? is six thousand pages long exactly mevin's thought that cleveland had slept with maria
好吧，既然这样，那这事就结案了。老实说，他并不是唯一一个得出这个结论的克利夫兰传记作家。20世纪大部分时间里最具权威的克利夫兰传记作家是一个叫艾伦·内文斯的人，他是哥伦比亚大学声誉极高的教授，曾获得普利策奖。他说这纯粹是共和党人的造谣中伤。这也是那些浩瀚的美国总统黑历史之一吗？整整六千页厚，内文斯就是这么想的，克利夫兰和玛丽亚
help in but um he said she was a loose woman now just because he's a distinguished historian doesn't mean he was right of course i mean we might well have different attitudes from alan evans but to repeat the key point we can never hear maria's voice there's no way of knowing which maria to believe so what happens to her no way does she live for long do people interview her after the kind of the turbulence and the high passions of the presidential campaign? No, she vanishes. She moved to New Rochelle, New York. She married again. She was widowed again. She married again. And she ended up dying in 1902. And just to sort of say farewell to Maria, the papers printed her dying wishes. They reported, oh, a woman who was in a famous scandal 20 years
有过关系。但呃，他说她是个不守妇道的女人。当然，他是个杰出的历史学家并不意味着他就一定是正确的，我的意思是，我们对艾伦·内文斯的态度可能大不相同。但重复关键的一点是，我们永远听不到玛丽亚的声音，没法知道该相信哪个玛丽亚。那她后来怎么样了？她活了很久吗？在总统竞选的狂风骤雨和高度激情之后，有人采访她吗？没有，她消失了。她搬到了纽约州新罗谢尔。她再次结婚。她又守寡了。她又结了一次婚。最后在1902年去世。为了跟玛丽亚告别，报纸刊登了她的遗愿。他们报道说，哦，一个在20年前卷入著名丑闻的女人
ago has died. And they printed her dying wishes. Do not let the funeral be too public. I do not want strangers to come and gaze on my face. Let me rest. Which is lovely, but I think is probably again made up. I mean, I don't believe somebody spoke like that on their deathbed. Oh, poor woman. So just people endlessly putting words into her mouth. Exactly. So let's tell people as well what happened to Grover Cleveland. To go back to the scandal, obviously some listeners may still think Grover Cleveland was guilty. Is it plausible, really? The whole thing was invented? On the other hand, is it plausible he behaved so badly? I'll tell you what I think right at the end of the episode, but just to tell you what happened to Cleveland himself and the other
去世了。他们刊登了她的遗愿。不要让葬礼太公开。我不想让陌生人来看我的脸。让我安息吧。这听起来挺感人的，但我认为很可能又是编造的。我是说，我不相信有人在临终前会说这样的话。哦，可怜的女人。所以大家只是无休止地把话塞进她嘴里。正是如此。那么我们顺便告诉大家格罗弗·克利夫兰后来怎么样了。回到这个丑闻本身，显然有些听众可能仍然认为格罗弗·克利夫兰有罪。这真的合理吗？整件事都是捏造的？另一方面，他行为如此恶劣合理吗？我会在节目最后告诉你们我的想法，但先告诉你们克利夫兰本人以及其他
characters. Cleveland became president. He was, he's famously a sort of quite a passive laissez-faire president. So he vetoed more spending bills than all his predecessors put together. So he's kind of a classical liberal in some ways. Limited government, sound money, all of this. He lost his bid for re-election to the ultimate AI-generated generic Gilded Age president, who's a man called Benjamin Harrison, who's actually, I mean, he's actually, he really is boring. I know we got into trouble before for calling Ulysses S. Grant boring, and our American listeners went berserk. I mean, Benjamin Harrison really is boring. He's very interested in tariffs.
人物的结局。克利夫兰当选了总统。他以奉行被动的自由放任主义而闻名。他否决的支出法案比他所有前任加起来还要多。所以在某种程度上，他算是个古典自由主义者。有限政府、健全货币，诸如此类。他输掉了连任竞选，败给了镀金时代那位终极AI生成的平庸总统，一个叫本杰明·哈里森的男人，他实际上，我是说，他真的挺无聊的。我知道我们之前因为说尤利西斯·S·格兰特无聊而惹过麻烦，我们的美国听众都抓狂了。我是说，本杰明·哈里森是真的无聊。他对关税非常感兴趣。
That's his big thing. But to be fair, Donald Trump's very interested in tariffs, and he's certainly not boring. No, he's not boring. It is possible to be interested in tariffs and still dominate the headlines. I think you've got to have more in your locker, and I don't think Benjamin Harrison does. Does he have a big beard? Massive. Absolutely massive. He was present for four years, and then in 1892, Cleveland ran again, and he, again, it was all
那是他的核心关税大业。不过公平地说，唐纳德·特朗普也非常对关税感兴趣，但他绝对不无聊。对，他不无聊。一个人可能对关税感兴趣，同时还能主导新闻头条。我觉得你得有点别的真本事，我不觉得本杰明·哈里森有。他有大胡子吗？巨大无比。绝对巨大无比。他当了四年总统，然后在1892年，克利夫兰再次参选，而且，又一次，核心全
about tariffs. Cleveland won again. Then he had a second term that was consumed by economic arguments. There was a massive depression. They have huge arguments about whether to inflate the currency with silver. It's very esoteric, I think, to modern audiences. Also, Cleveland disgraced himself, actually, Tom. He took Venezuela's side in a boundary dispute with Great Britain. Oh, my God. And they almost came to war. He almost went to war with Lord Salisbury.
都是关税。克利夫兰再次获胜。然后他的第二任期被经济争论所吞噬。当时发生了一场大萧条。关于是否用白银来增加货币流通，他们产生了巨大的争论。对于现代观众来说，这可能非常深奥。还有，克利夫兰实际上让自己名誉扫地了，汤姆。在与英国的边界争端中，他站在了委内瑞拉一边。哦，天哪。他们差点开战。他差点和索尔斯伯里勋爵打起来。
Now, here's the thing that will make you think differently about Cleveland, possibly. When Cleveland became president, he was still a bachelor. Now, people said, gosh, is this not the point where he could marry his friend's widow, Emma? Now, he's been very nice to Emma and to her daughter, Francis. He's bought Francis lots of presents. He bought her a puppy. He has bought her a puppy. and she calls him Uncle Cleve.
现在，有一点可能会让你对克利夫兰改观，也许吧。当克利夫兰成为总统时，他仍然是个单身汉。当时人们说，天哪，这难道不是他娶朋友遗孀埃玛的好时机吗？此前他对埃玛和她的女儿弗朗西斯一直很好。他给弗朗西斯买了很多礼物。他给她买了一只小狗。他确实给她买了一只小狗。而她叫他克利夫恩叔叔。
Is she? Now, Francis has grown into a very glamorous young woman. She goes off to Wells College, which is a sort of liberal arts college straight finishing school. And her friends at Wells College noticed that she's got a regular correspondent who sends her bouquets of red roses. Now, you may be wondering, who is this dashing young Swain? Who has stolen her heart?
是吗？现在，弗朗西斯已经长成了一个非常迷人的年轻女性。她去了韦尔斯学院，那是一所类似文理学院的淑女学校。她在韦尔斯学院的朋友们发现，她有一个固定的通信者，会给她寄红玫瑰花束。现在，你可能在想，这个风流倜傥的追求者是谁？究竟是谁偷走了她的芳心？
Is it Uncle Cleve? It is Uncle Cleve. So as soon as she's graduated, he proposes. He's 48. She's 21. They get married in the White House. And do you know what? It's very successful and happy.
难道是克利夫恩叔叔？没错，就是克利夫恩叔叔。所以她一毕业，他就求婚了。他48岁。她21岁。他们在白宫结婚了。你知道吗？这段婚姻非常成功且幸福。
Everybody loves her. They had five children. The newspapers, I have to say, very ungallantly, speculated whether Cleveland, who is now about 80 Stone, whether he would crush her on their wedding night. So aside from the weight, he's basically the Woody Allen of American presidents.
每个人都喜欢她。他们有五个孩子。不过我必须说，报纸非常不绅士地猜测，当时体重已经达到大约80英石的克利夫兰，会不会在新婚之夜把她压扁。所以除了体重之外，他基本上就是美国总统里的伍迪·艾伦。
I guess so. I hadn't thought of that. And, of course, another New Yorker. Yeah, so. Anyway, he left office in 1897 and he retired to Princeton. He died in 1908. Francis married a Princeton professor. She died in 1947, which is the same year that his son died. I mean, this is a guy who really, you know, lost to history, Oscar Folsom Cleveland. So what happened to him? Well, remember, he ended up being taken by the doctor.
我想是的。我之前没想到这一点。当然，他也是个纽约人。对，所以。总之，他在1897年卸任，退休搬到了普林斯顿。他于1908年去世。弗朗西斯嫁给了一位普林斯顿教授。她于1947年去世，同年他的儿子也去世了。我是说，这家伙真的，你知道，被历史遗忘了，奥斯卡·福尔松·克利夫兰。那他怎么样了？好吧，别忘了，他最后被那个医生带走了。
Dr. King. Dr. King. Well, here's the thing. He spent the whole of the rest of his life as James E. King, Jr. he clearly got on well with his parents. And when you say parents, do you mean the doctor, Dr. King? Yes, Dr. King and his wife. Because he remained close to his mother in particular after his father died. And he followed his father into the same area of medicine. His father had been an obstetrician and James E. King, Jr. became a gynecologist.
金医生。金医生。事情是这样的。他的余生都作为小詹姆斯·E·金生活。他显然跟养父母关系很好。你说的父母是指那个医生，金医生吗？对，金医生和他的妻子。因为他在父亲去世后，特别是跟他母亲保持着亲密的关系。他追随父亲的脚步进入了同一领域的医学界。他父亲曾是一名产科医生，而小詹姆斯·E·金成为了一名妇科医生。
And does he ever investigate who his real father might have been or anything? Oh, he knows who his real father is, I think. But who is his real father? Because we don't know. Grover Cleveland or Folstham or. Well, okay, here's my verdict. I have to admit, when I first read this story, I assumed that Cleveland was guilty. But while preparing the episode, and I also influenced by the excellent judgment of Troy Seneck.
那他有没有调查过自己的亲生父亲可能是谁之类的？哦，我想他知道自己的亲生父亲是谁。但他的亲生父亲究竟是谁呢？因为我们并不知道。是格罗弗·克利夫兰还是福尔松还是……好吧，这是我的裁决。我必须承认，当我第一次读到这个故事时，我以为克利夫兰是有罪的。但在准备这期节目时，我也受到了特洛伊·塞尼克卓越判断力的影响，
I came to change my mind. It's for three reasons. Number one, because we never hear Maria's voice and mediated by Republican journalists, I think you cannot say Cleveland's guilty beyond reasonable doubt. I mean, that's just not possible. you know, because we've never heard her evidence, really. Number two, the initial accusations were so lurid and so mad. Cleveland having bar fights and saloons.
我改变了主意。原因有三。第一，因为我们从未听到玛丽亚的声音，而且这一切都经过了共和党记者的转述，我认为你不能毫无合理怀疑地判定克利夫兰有罪。我的意思是，这根本不可能。你知道的，因为我们从来没有真正听到过她的证据。第二，最初的指控实在是荒诞离奇、疯狂至极。比如克利夫兰在酒吧和沙龙里打群架。
Yeah, I mean, that's what immediately leaps out at you when you were telling it, was that the contradiction between the image of him as kind of sober and respectable and the idea that he's getting arrested in bars. I mean, surely there would be a police record if that was the case. Exactly, of course. Well, you're not if you're the sheriff. This is the show. I guess not.
对，我的意思是，当你讲述的时候，最先跳进脑海的就是这种矛盾：他那种清醒、体面的形象，与他在酒吧被捕的想法之间的矛盾。我的意思是，如果是真的，肯定会有警方记录吧。没错，当然会有。如果你是治安官，那就另当别论了。这就是问题所在。我想也是。
It's like sort of Gene Hunt in Life on Mars. But obviously he wasn't that personality, right? He's just not that. So all of that stuff. So if all of that stuff is mad and invented, then the rest of it is surely tainted. You know, I don't think you can pick and choose. Can I also ask, so when the Harvey Weinstein scandal broke,
这有点像《火星生活》里的吉恩·亨特。但显然他不是那种性格，对吧？他根本不是那样的人。所以所有那些东西都是假的。如果所有这些东西都是疯狂且虚构的，那么其余部分肯定也是有问题的。你知道的，我觉得你不能挑肥拣瘦。我还可以问一下吗，当哈维·韦恩斯坦丑闻曝光时，
lots of women came forward. Yes. And that's a kind of familiar pattern with famous men who... are kind of nailed for being sexual predators. Are there any other women who come forward? No. I mean, that's not conclusive. Obviously, it's not conclusive, but it's suggestive perhaps.
许多女性站了出来。是的。对于那些被扣上性掠夺者帽子的名人来说，这是一种熟悉的模式。还有其他女性站出来吗？没有。我的意思是，这并非决定性的证据。当然，这算不上决定性的证据，但也许能说明一些问题。
There had never been the slightest whiff of scandal. And this is the third point. So Cleveland's character. Now, it is absolutely true that a lot of apparently very boring and very decent men turn out to be very bad men, sexual abusers or rapists or whatever. But is it plausible that this man who's basically a man's man's man and he likes a cigar and stuff, but he's also a massive workaholic with a reputation for incorruptibility and honesty and so on. Is it really plausible all the stuff about kidnapping the baby, locking this woman in an asylum, you know, all of that?
此前从未有过一丝丑闻的迹象。这就是第三点。也就是克利夫兰的性格。现在，确实有很多表面上非常无聊、非常正派的人，最后被证明是非常糟糕的人，比如性虐待者、强奸者之类。但这个基本上是个纯粹的硬汉、喜欢雪茄之类的家伙，同时也是一个以廉洁奉公、诚实正直等品质闻名的大工作狂，所有关于绑架婴儿、把这个女人关进疯人院等等的说法，真的合理吗？
Given what we know of his character, is that plausible as well, I find that hard to believe. And I think because you have to take the whole package, you know, or none of it, I'm much more tempted to take none of it. The fact that he knew Maria and he may have slept with her and may have got her pregnant. Yeah. I mean, that is the kind of the stratum on which perhaps this kind of more lurid melodrama is constructed. And on that theme, I just wondered, kind of listening to this, whether fabricated scandals are like, faked paintings in that it can take the passage of decades or a century before you realize that it has been faked. Because when it's constructed, if it's part of the general culture, if everyone
结合我们对他人格的了解，这合理吗？我觉得这很难相信。正因为你必须全盘接受，要么全盘否定，我更倾向于全盘否定。他认识玛丽亚，可能和她睡过，也可能让她怀了孕。对。我的意思是，这或许正是构建这种更荒诞的闹剧的底层土壤。顺着这个主题，我只是在想，听了这些之后，虚构的丑闻是否就像造假的画作一样，可能需要几十甚至一个世纪的时间，人们才会意识到它是假的？因为当它被构建出来时，如果它是大众文化的一部分，如果每个人
is reading melodramas in which women are locked up in asylums, maybe it seems plausible, but at a distance, you start to recognize that the implausibility within the plots of the melodramers is also suggestive of an implausibility within the story that's being constructed. Maybe, although I think, to me, I think a lot of people at the time thought this was clearly nonsense. So it's not just you Mark Twain's
都在阅读女性被关在疯人院里的通俗剧，也许它看起来很合理，但拉开距离后，你开始意识到通俗剧情节中的不合理之处，同时也暗示了正在构建的故事本身的不合理性。也许吧，尽管我认为，对我来说，当时很多人就认为这纯粹是无稽之谈。所以不仅仅是你，马克·吐温
and people who are already very party-pre. But I think the fact that the story vanishes so quickly and that, as you say, no one else does come forward, there are no Republicans halfway through Cleveland's term saying, it's unbelievable this man is in the White House. He's an illegitimate president. It's disgusting that we've sunk to such a low, all of them. Which you would say if you thought this was true, wouldn't you?
以及那些本身就带有强烈党派倾向的人这么看。但我认为，这个故事消失得如此之快，而且正如你所说，没有其他人站出来，在克利夫兰任期过半时，也没有任何共和党人说：这个人在白宫里简直难以置信。他是个非法的总统。我们竟然沦落到这种地步，太令人作呕了，所有这些。如果你真觉得这是真的，你肯定会这么说，对吧？
Well, yeah, maybe. There's a slight sense of the Republicans. They tried it on. It didn't work. They moved on. Yeah, they've moved on. Would they have moved on so quickly? I mean, listen, this is not a definitive verdict by any means.
好吧，也许吧。有一种共和党人浅尝辄止的感觉。他们试了一下。没成功。然后就往前看了。对，他们已经往前看了。他们会这么快就翻篇吗？听着，这绝不是一个定论。
So it's not proven, but balanced probability. I would say. In fact, deep down, I think probably Oscar Folsom was the father, which is why Cleveland gave the boy. I mean, that seems very strange otherwise. That's the thing about history, isn't it, Tom? You know, we don't pretend, we don't purport to be the Oracle. I mean, Troy Seneca may think we are, but we're not the experts and everything, aren't we? And sometimes it's just unknowable.
所以这并未得到证实，但从权衡可能性的角度来看。我会这么说。事实上，内心里，我猜奥斯卡·福尔松可能才是父亲，这就是为什么克利夫兰要把这个男孩送走。我的意思是，除此之外，这似乎太奇怪了。这就是历史的奇妙之处，对吧，汤姆？你知道，我们不装，我们不自诩为神谕。我的意思是，特洛伊·塞尼克可能觉得我们是，但我们并不是无所不知的专家，对吧？有时事情就是无从知晓。
Well, I think listeners can make up their own minds there. So thank you, Dominic. I now know a good deal more about Grover Cleveland than I did. I suspect that's true of many of our listeners. Thank you all for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，我想听众们可以自己做出判断。所以谢谢你，多米尼克。我现在对格罗弗·克利夫兰的了解比以前多多了。我猜我们的很多听众也是如此。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。